sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren dies ist mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit die letzte sitzung
des deutschen bundestages in dieser
legislaturperiode und gerade in den
letzten tagen haben wir es mit sehr
dramatischen problemen zu tun eben ist
das thema afghanistan hier genannt
worden ich will die gelegenheit nutzen
da wir ja nach der letzten ausführlichen
debatte noch nicht die möglichkeit
hatten unseren soldatinnen und soldaten
die dort an dieser schwierigen
evakuierungs mission beteiligt waren ein
ganz herzliches dankeschön zu sagen das
war einer der schwierigsten einsätze
und da ist in der tat nicht gelungen ist
insbesondere im bereich der
entwicklungspolitik alle
schutzbedürftigen personen zu evakuieren
war es richtig dass der
bundesaußenminister auf eine reise
gegangen ist in die nachbarstaaten um
diese probleme zu besprechen wie wir aus
reisen auch in zukunft möglich machen
und unserer verantwortung nachkommen und
genauso war es richtig mit den
nachbarstaaten darüber zu reden wie wir
humanitäre probleme dort zu lösen helfen
genauso wie wir uns um die humanitäre
lage in afghanistan ganz besonders im
blick auf hunger und medizinische
versorgung weiter kümmern werden
ansonsten haben wir eine ausführliche
diskussion ja vor 14 tagen geführt und
was die sorgen im innenpolitischen
bereich anbelangt so hat das
insbesondere mit der furchtbaren
flutkatastrophe zu tun ich war in der
vergangenen woche am freitag und am
sonntag noch einmal in den flutgebieten
und darf nur sagen es ist richtig und
wichtig dass wir heute den hilft hilfe
von in höhe von 30 milliarden euro
verabschieden und ich habe den menschen
zugesagt und ich denke das kann ich wird
hier von allen geteilt wir werden die
menschen die von dieser schrecklichen
furchtbaren flut betroffen sind nicht
vergessen der wiederaufbau wird jahre
monate jahre dauern und deshalb brauchen
wir
und das habe ich ihm zugedacht und
dieses flutkatastrophe hat natürlich als
extremwetterereignisse den fokus noch
einmal auf eines der drängendsten themen
unserer zeit geworfen nämlich auf den
kampf gegen den klimawandel
und deshalb will ich an dieser stelle
noch einmal darauf hinweisen dass wir
wichtige weichen gestellt haben in
dieser legislaturperiode als ich
bundeskanzlerin wurde im jahr 2005 daten
wir zehn prozent der erzeugung von
energie aus für den strom aus
erneuerbaren energie heute liegen wir
deutlich über 40 prozent aber viel
wichtiger sind die systemischen dinge
die wir in dieser legislaturperiode in
angriff genommen werden und haben und
auf die wir auch zukünftige regierungen
aufbauen können das ist ein
klimaschutzgesetz mit jährlichen budgets
und sektor zielen bis ein expertenrat
und das sind nach steuerungs pflichten
also ein instrumentarium mit dem wir
wirklich bindende möglichkeiten in der
hand haben
zweitens haben wir die bepreisung von
co2 eingeführt ein marktwirtschaftliches
instrument mit dem wir auf die reduktion
von co2 viel besser reagieren können wir
haben inzwischen eine millionen
elektroautos wir haben den ausstieg aus
der braunkohle miteinander vereinbart im
übrigen im gesellschaftlichen konsens
eine ganz wichtige sache den klimaschutz
kann nur dann gelingen wenn die menschen
im lande auch mitgenommen werden und das
war immer der ansatz der großen
koalition und das war auch richtig so
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir alle
spüren ja und in den letzten jahren hat
das aus meiner sicht zugenommen dass die
welt eine welt in unruhe und im umbruch
ist und das völlig neue
herausforderungen uns beschäftigen und
natürlich auch deutschland beschäftigen
das ist terrorismus dass das cyber
kriminalität dass es die technologische
revolution der digitalisierung das ist
die ökonomische stärke von china und
neben dem klimawandel ist es vor allen
dingen die digitalisierung die unser
leben vollkommen verändert
und wir haben uns in der großen
koalition immer vorgenommen möglichst
viele menschen so wie es eben beim
klimawandel gesagt habe mitzunehmen auf
die sind bei diesen wandel und deshalb
war ein zentrales thema unserer arbeit
in den letzten jahren die
gleichwertigkeit der lebensverhältnisse
in ganz deutschland zu sichern und zwar
zwischen ost und west zwischen stadt und
land eine vielzahl der maßnahmen der
bundesregierung hat sich genau mit
diesem thema
beschäftigt ich kann hier nur
stichpunkte nennen behörden
verlagerungen insbesondere in die neuen
bundesländer stärkung der ländlichen
räume das thema wohnen in
ballungsgebieten mit regulierung neubau
von wohnungen neu bau von
sozialwohnungen das wohneigentum für
familien wir haben eine ehrenamts
stiftung gegründet um das ehrenamt in
unserem land zu stärken und wir haben ja
gesehen welche bedeutung dieses ehrenamt
hat jetzt gerade in den großen
herausforderungen wie das katastrophe
oder der pandemie und wir haben die
kommunen gestärkt insbesondere auch
durch übernahme von kdu kosten von
kosten der unterkunft für die kommunen
ein ganz wesentlicher punkt um politik
überhaupt lebbar zu machen wir haben den
rechtsstaat gestärkt durch einen
einzigartigen aufbau von mehr personal
und mehr möglichkeiten und wir haben den
kampf gegen den extremismus insbesondere
den rechtsextremismus durchgeführt und
bei den großen thema digitalisierung
haben wir entscheidende fortschritte
erzielt will daran erinnern dass wir
inzwischen behördengänge dass wir
inzwischen verwaltungsleistungen digital
anbieten insbesondere die des bundes wir
haben den die infrastruktur ausgebaut
breitbandanschlüsse mehr als 50 megabit
pro sekunde waren am anfang dieser
legislaturperiode 80 prozent jetzt sind
es 94 prozent wir haben eine
verfügbarkeit von lte anschlüssen
mobilfunk von über 99 prozent das sind
dinge die kann man benennen es gibt
kleine schwierigkeiten nach wie vor an
vielen stellen blaue flecken und ähnlich
ist aber meine damen und herren im
großen ganzen haben wir deutliche
fortschritte gemacht und das war richtig
so
mit dem digital parkschule haben wir mit
den ländern gemeinsam 6,5 milliarden
euro investiert die müssen jetzt
umgesetzt werden wir haben für digitale
innovation 13,5 milliarden euro
eingesetzt und ich will noch einmal
darauf hinweisen die öffentlichen
investitionen haben sich seit dem jahre
2005 genau verdoppelt das heißt also ein
schwerpunkt liegt bei den investitionen
und ein zentraler punkt das ist liegt
der schwerpunkt auf wissenschaft und
forschung das ist die quelle unseres
wohlstands für die zukunft und deshalb
kann man sagen als wir 2005 als sich
bundeskanzlerin wurde waren die ausgaben
für forschung und entwicklung lagen bei
24 prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts
heute sind wir bei 3,05 prozent wir
haben deutliche planungssicherheit für
die zwanziger jahre durch pakte für
forschungs wissenschafts packte
exzellenz strategie und vieles andere
mehr und du machst das
dem ein oder anderen sehr abstrakt
erscheinen aber das hat etwas mit
unserem wohlstand und mit unserem leben
zu tun und das haben wir in der pandemie
erlebt der erste und bis heute
zuverlässigste tests zum nachweis des
virus wurde bereits zu beginn der
pandemie in deutschland in der charité
in berlin entwickelt und einer der
überaus wirkungsvollen emma impfstoff
gegen das virus wurde auch in
deutschland entwickelt auch dank
langjähriger zielgerichteter
forschungsförderung und nebenbei gesagt
natürlich war und ist niemand von uns
beim impfen in irgendeiner form ein
versuchskaninchen niemand bilder oder
scholz
denn jeder
in jeder der in deutschland seit ende
dezember letzten jahres wurde bekam
einen impfstoff der alle notwendigen
phasen der klinischen prüfung und
notwendigen zulassungsverfahren
durchlaufen hat wir sind uns doch alle
einig dass noch viel mehr menschen davon
überzeugt werden müssen geimpft zu
werden doch wenn wir die menschen davon
überzeugen wollen dann hat das mit
argumenten zu geschehen und nicht mit
zurückhaltend formuliert schiefen
bildern von versuchs gar nicht
was also sind die argumente für das
impfen impfen wirkt man schützt sich und
die liebsten
impfen bringt uns die freiheit zurück
und je mehr menschen geimpft sind umso
kleiner ist die gefahr dass sich neue
mutationen bilden gegen die impfstoffe
nicht mehr wirken und so aus diesem
grunde möchte ich auch von dieser stelle
heute noch einmal alle die noch nicht
geimpft sind bitten lassen sie sich
impfen sie leisten damit für sich und
unsere gesamte gesellschaft einen ganz
wichtigen beitrag den weg aus dieser
familie
[Musik]
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
alle wissen diese pandemie war
wahrscheinlich der schwerste
eingriff in unser gesellschaftliches
leben seit gründung der bundesrepublik
deutschland und es war gut dass wir
wegen solider haushaltspolitik in der
lage waren an einer solchen
außergewöhnlichen situationen sowohl im
inland das größte konjunkturpaket
auflegen zu können dass es jemals gab in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland als auch in europa mit dem
wiederaufbau von in dieser ganz
speziellen situation einen neuen weg zu
beschreiten und europa auch gut aus
dieser krise zu führen und das heute die
zahl der kurzarbeiter wieder unter einer
million liegt dass die arbeitslosigkeit
deutlich unter 2 5 millionen
2005 war sie fünf millionen heute die
hälfte das ist solide haushaltspolitik
und richtigen entscheidungen ab anämie
zu verdanken auf die große koalition
insgesamt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen in
weniger als drei wochen ist
bundestagswahl
sie ist eine besondere wahl nicht nur
weil sich erstmals seit 1949 kein
amtierender bundeskanzler
beziehungsweise bundeskanzlerin um die
wiederwahl bewirbt sondern es ist auch
eine besondere wahl weil es in
schwierigsten zeiten eine
richtungsentscheidung für unser land ist
und ist es nicht egal wer dieses land
regiert die bürgerinnen haben
in wenigen tagen die wahl entweder eine
regierung die mit spd und grünen die
unterstützung der linkspartei in kauf
nimmt zumindest sie nicht ausschließt
oder
[Applaus]
ja sagt er nur die wahrheit
zumindest nicht ausschließen
oder eine von cdu/csu und armin laschet
als bundeskanzler geführte
bundesregierung eine bundesregierung die
müssen maß und mitte unser land in die
zib ist
und was dabei geht es wahrlich nicht
allein um die außenpolitik die nato und
europa
meine güte was für eine aufregung ich
bin seit 30 jahren über 30 jahren
mitglied dieses deutschen bundestags und
ich weiß nicht wo wenn nicht hier solche
fragen diskutiert werden müssen das ist
die haupt aber der demokratie und die am
besten habe das diskutieren
über diese richtungsentscheidung dieses
wahrlich nicht allein um die
außenpolitik die nato und europa das
auch aber eben nicht allein sondern es
geht auch um handfeste die
wirtschaftspolitische und
steuerpolitischer entscheidungen die die
zukunft dieses landes bestimmen werden
die zahl der arbeitsplätze und unserem
gemeinsamen wohlstand und der seine
damen und herren
der besten weg für unser land ist seine
cdu csu geführten bundesregierung mit
armin laschet als bundeskanzler denn
seine regierung soll für stabilität
verlässlichkeit maß und mitte stehen und
das ist genau das was deutschland
greifen
zu viel versprochen selten sind sie
warten so lebhafte jetzt kurz vor der
wahl angela merkel die scheidende
kanzlerin zog eine positive bilanz ihrer
regierungszeit und stellte sich dann
ungewohnt deutlich hinter armin laschet
warnte vor einer möglichen rot grün
roten regierung
die nächste rednerin die
spitzenkandidatin der afg alice beide
auch das eher ungewohnt und in einer
solchen generaldebatte dass die
kanzlerin so viel applaus erhält
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
das war gerade ein phänomenales
schauspiel ich weiß gar nicht gehört
angela merkel eigentlich noch der cdu
csu an ich habe das irgendwie nicht
mitbekommen und ich darf sie auch daran
erinnern dass es die cdu gewesen ist
angela merkel die einen linken
ministerpräsidenten in thüringen
zugelassen hat das ist ihr verdienst und
genau deshalb stehen sie so auch in den
umfragen da wir sind derzeit stehen ihre
letzte amtszeit von merkel war für
deutschland eine periode des
beschleunigten abstiegs ihrem nachfolger
wird ein sanierungsfall hinterlassen ein
land das verunsichert und gespalten ist
ein land dessen repräsentanten sich in
der rolle des moralischen oberlehrers
gefallen aber im ernstfall an konkreten
herausforderungen
dilettantisch scheitern und versagen ein
land dessen wohlstand erodiert und dass
seine ressourcen in beispielloser weise
vergeudet und verschenkt mit dem corona
wieder auf bauvorhaben sie die deutschen
steuerzahler endgültig an eine schulden-
und transferunion ausgeliefert die ezb
geld schwemme ist in der steigenden
inflation der verbraucherpreise
angekommen zusammen mit dem
manipulierten 0 und negativzinsen
bedeutet dass die organisierte massen
enteignung der bürger mit hunderten
milliarden wohlstandsverlust görlitz
der 1 spürt dass auf seinem konto das
keine zinsen mehr abwirft und an seinem
kaufkraftverlust deutschland belegt bei
dem privatvermögen ebenso wie beim
rentenniveau einen verlierer platz in
der stadt das rentensystem demografie
fest zu reformieren machen sie
ungedeckte zahlungsversprechen wie es
nach 20.30 weitergehen soll wenn die
geburtenstarken jahrgänge in rente gehen
dafür haben sie keinen plan dafür haben
wir den höchsten schuldenberg unserer
nachkriegsgeschichte nach anderthalb
jahren corona schuldenpolitik ist die
offene staatsschuld um volle zehn
prozentpunkte von 60 auf 70 prozent des
bips gestiegen zusammen mit der
impliziten staatsschuld der
nachhaltigkeitslücke sind das
440 prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes
oder
14,7 billionen euro ihr vizekanzler und
koalitionspartner olaf scholz hat als
finanzminister diesen schuldenberg
maßgeblich zu verantworten und herr
scholz redet viel von respekt hat aber
wenig respekt für die hart arbeitenden
normalen leute die jeden tag aufstehen
zur arbeit fahren groß ziehen und dafür
laufend bestraft werden ihre regierung
hat keinen respekt für die menschen und
auch nicht für die mittelständischen
unternehmer und familienbetriebe die
millionen menschen arbeit geben und wenn
es nach rot grün links geht über eine
asoziale vermögens und erbschaftssteuer
enteignet werden sollen demgegenüber
steht der rückfall ins untere mittelmaß
in fast allen bereichen um nur zwei zu
nennen das bildungswesen und die
digitalisierung in mathematik und
naturwissenschaften sind die leistungen
deutscher schüler unter den eu
durchschnitt gefallen im internationalen
vergleichstest deutschland seit 2007 vom
zwölften auf den 25 platz gefallen im
digitalen ranking steht deutschland
inzwischen an drittletzter stelle unter
den g20-staaten abgehängt auch von
frankreich und italien an dass wir
dutzende milliarden an sogenannte korona
wiederaufbauhilfe leisten ein weiteres
ungelöstes problem dieser regierung ist
die migrations krise
nach wie vor wandert jedes jahr eine
großstadt neu in unser land reisen und
direkt in die sozialsysteme dass sie das
super finden das wissen wir es reicht
offenbar nicht was sie mit ihrem
vorsätzlichen rechtsbuch von 2015 über
dieses land und seine bürger gebracht
haben jetzt missbraucht diese regierung
die ortskräfte die der bundeswehr in
afghanistan gedient haben um die nächste
einwanderungswelle nach deutschland
loszutreten von rund 4.000 bis im
unterland der akku afghanen waren ganze
168 ortskräfte aber mehr als 250
personen ganz ohne papiere darunter
bereits abgeschobene straftäter polizei
bekannte kriminelle vergewaltiger
kinderschänder
islamisten die auf staatskosten geholt
wurden und in folge des neuerlichen
abschiebestopps auf unabsehbare zeit
bleiben werden während andere staaten
sich auf die sicherheit und die
rohstoffe in der region fokussieren
interessiert sich die deutsche politik
vor allem für die evakuierung von
ausreisewilligen afghanen das versagen
in der asyl- und migrationspolitik wird
als größte fehler ist der endzeit von
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen
die potenzielle zukunfts belastung für
unser land summiert sich auf über eine
billion euro noch schwerer wiegt der
schaden den der kontrollverlust für den
inneren frieden die sicherheit der
bürger das vertrauen in die institution
und den inneren zusammenhalt des landes
bedeutet auch ihre fehlgeleitete
klimaschutz und energiewende politik
wird teuer zu stehen kommen aber
milliarde werden jahr für jahr verbrannt
um die taschen der windkraft und
ökostrom lobby zu füllen während
deutschland sich in planwirtschaftlichen
gestrüpp von e-autos subventionierung
und co2 besteuerung verheddert die
irrationale idee
kohle und atomkraftwerke
gleichzeitig abzuschalten braucht einem
industrieland wie deutschland den
lebensnerv die sichere und bezahlbare
energieversorgung
mit dem gleichen furor wollen sie die
elektromobilität herbei subventionieren
ohne sich um die fragwürdige
umweltbilanz und die begrenzte
verfügbarkeit der rohstoffe für die
dafür erforderliche batterieproduktion
zu kümmern woher übrigens der
zusätzliche strom für all die
elektroautos kommen soll die sie auf die
straße bringen wollen darüber haben sie
sich offensichtlich keine gedanken
gemacht
oder glauben sie ernsthaft sie könnten
die deutsche industrie auf wind- und
sonnenstrom und grünen wasserstoff
umstellen wissen sie was sie dafür
brauchen
dafür müssten sie die zahl der windräder
auf
330.000 verzehnfachen und ein viertel
der landesfläche mit rotor türmen zu
betonieren und wenn dann der wind nicht
weht dann drehen sich diese trotzdem
nicht sie zu nachhaltige politik aus wir
sagen ganz klar
mit solchen unausgegorenen ideen machen
sie unser land zum gespött der welt und
die deutschen zu verlierern im globalen
wettbewerb
niemand europa oder anderswo auf der
welt denkt ernsthaft daran die deutsche
energiewende zu kopieren wir sind der
einzige gp start und das muss man hier
ganz klar so sagen der einzige staat der
diese durchgeknallten ideen ernsthaft
umsetzen möchte koste was es wolle
whatever it takes wie draghi zu sagen
pflegt in den letzten zwei jahrzehnten
hat sich der strompreis in deutschland
verdoppelt und die eeg-umlage seit 2004
verzehnfacht als folge der weltfremden
klimaziele dieser koalition droht im
nächsten jahr über die anhebung der
sogenannten co2 bepreisung der anstieg
der spritkosten und bis zu 70 cent pro
liter das bedeutet preise weit jenseits
der zwei euro marke auch wenn der
verkehrsminister anderes verspricht das
schützt weder das klima noch rettet es
dem planeten aber es macht pendler und
familien arm die auf das auto angewiesen
sind es ruiniert mittelständler und
treibt die produktive industrie und
hunderttausende von arbeitsplätzen aus
diesem land
neben all diesen finanziell lassen
beunruhigt eine zahl in der bilanz der
regierung besonders von allen eu bürgern
fühlen die deutschen sich am wenigsten
frei
nur elf prozent sehen sich noch als frei
in ihrem alltagsleben die
orientierungslose und maßlose corona
politik dieser bundesregierung hatte
daran erheblichen anteil
besuchen immer mehr unsere europäischen
nachbarn den weg zurück in die
normalität sie aber mauern dieses land
mitsamt seinen menschen in einem
permanenten ausnahmezustand ein und
stach mit vernunft und augenmaß
obsolet gewordene maßnahmen
zurückzufahren schikanieren sie schüler
und jugendliche auch im neuen schuljahr
mit masken und des regimes deren nutzen
bis heute nicht bewiesen ist und sie
brechen abermals das versprechen dass
sie den bürgern gegeben haben und zwar
wenn jeder der dazu bereit ist ein
impfangebot gemacht wurde müssen die
maßnahmen
es liegt jetzt in der verantwortung
jedes einzelnen
und seiner persönlichen risiko abwägung
ob er sich für eine impfung oder andere
vorkehrungen zu seinem eigenen schutz
entscheidet oder nicht es ist eine
individuelle entscheidung und sie
spalten das land und die gesellschaft
wenn sie menschen aufgrund dieser
persönlichen entscheidung
gegeneinander ausspielen und ungeimpfte
als bürger zweiter klasse vom
gesellschaftlichen leben ausschließen
alle alarmglocken schrillen denn auf
politiker munz ungeimpfte als sozial
schädlinge diffamiert werden und selbst
ein vizekanzler geimpfte als
versuchskaninchen bezeichnet und sie
üben faktischen impfzwang aus um es so
zu nennen um sich aus der verantwortung
für die folgen ihrer falschen
entscheidungen zu stehlen seit
anderthalb jahren betreiben sie unter
dem namen der pandemie bekämpfung eine
politik der gebrochenen versprechen und
der überzogenen grundrechts
einschränkungen von reiseeinschränkungen
und lockte am berufsverboten über
ausgangssperren und notstandsmaßnahmen
diffamierung und
demonstrationsverbote gegen kritiker bis
zum impfzwang und drastischen eingriffen
in die eltern und kinderrechte und sie
sagen sie hören auf die wissenschaft
werden sie jetzt schon wieder
spekulieren wäre ich in neuen
grundrechts entzüge sie nach der wahl
wieder umsetzen könnten und meinen damit
stets nur jene wissenschaftler die ihnen
nach dem mund reden nehmen sie also
endlich andere standpunkte zur kenntnis
zum beispiel die stimme der 100 ärzten
juristen
und unternehmer die in einem offenen
brief klaren und verbindlichen aussagen
zum ende der pandemie politik fordert
hören sie auf mit angstparolen und
panikmache die bürger von den vielen
drängenden themen abzulenken
stellen sie endlich die grundrechte
vollumfänglich und für alle wieder her
damit dieses land zur normalität
zurückkehren und sich nach einer
schonungslosen und ehrlichen
bestandsaufnahme der gesamtheit seiner
probleme und herausforderungen
zuwenden kann ich bedanke mich
merkel hinterlasse einen sanierungsfall
ein land dessen wohlstand erodiere ein
land das zum gespött der welt werde so
die heftige kritik von alice seidel von
der alb gegen migration digitalisierung
bildung all dies seien ungelöste problem
nächster redner ist nun der
kanzlerkandidat der spd wonach stolze 10
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren wir nähern uns dem ende
einer legislaturperiode die anders
verlaufen ist als wir uns das alle
dachten
wir halten als regierung sie als
abgeordnete und natürlich die
bürgerinnen und bürger wir haben alle
mit der größten herausforderung unseres
wiedervereinigten landes zu tun gehabt
wir haben jetzt eine sehr sehr lange
zeit miteinander gegen die korona krise
gekämpft haben gemeinsam gekämpft um die
gesundheit der bürgerinnen und bürger
gekämpft damit arbeitsplätze und
unternehmen durch diese krise kommen und
damit ein aufschwung kommt damit es auch
in zukunft noch arbeitsplätze gibt und
es ist uns gelungen so weit zu kommen
wie wir heute gekommen sind weil wir
zusammengehalten haben
wir haben zusammengehalten als ganzes
land aber das will ich ausdrücklich
dafür zu sagen wir haben auch zusammen
gehalten als regierung und all die
notwendigen maßnahmen auf den weg
gebracht die man unternehmen muss damit
man eine so große herausforderung
bewältigen kann und deshalb möchte ich
am ende dieser legislaturperiode
angesichts dieser großen unerwarteten
herausforderungen sagen einen schönen
dank für die zusammenarbeit auch an sie
frau bundeskanzlerin dr
jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir eine
situation die sehr viel anders ist viele
bürgerinnen und bürger sind geimpft das
ist ein anderer zustand als wir im
letzten jahr hatten und deshalb dürfen
wir hoffen dass der herbst und winter
der jetzt vor uns liegt anders verläuft
als der herbst und winter den wir hinter
uns hatten und für mich gibt es deshalb
auch ein paar dinge die man hier klar
aussprechen kann wir werden keinen neuen
lockdown haben und wir können die kinder
die schüler mitschüler auch wieder im
präsenzunterricht in den schulen haben
was wir dazu tun müssen was wir dazu tun
müssen ist natürlich weiter dafür zu
werben dass möglichst viele bürgerinnen
und bürger sich impfen lassen denn die
hohe zahl der geimpften ändert nichts
daran dass es besser wäre noch mehr
würden müssten und das will ich
ausdrücklich dazu sagen ich finde es
wäre falsch wenn jetzt eine debatte
beginnt über die pflichten und ähnliches
was wir machen müssen ist die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu überzeugen und
auch das finde ich gerne sagen wir
müssen dafür sorge tragen dass wir sie
überzeugen indem wir das machen
lockergelassen auch mit witzen über die
auf vielen veranstaltungen gelacht wird
wenn einige nicht lachen wollen und
darüber sich aufregen hat das vielleicht
etwas damit zu tun dass sie beim blick
auf ihre umfragewerte wenig zu lachen
haben
und deshalb auch mein wunsch macht das
was durch impfen es ist gut für euch es
ist gut für eure liebsten es ist gut für
diejenigen darauf die ihr wert lebt und
deshalb überzeugt die kolleginnen und
kollegen im betrieb überzeugt die
freunde im sportverein die kollegen und
freunde am stammtisch alles das gehört
dazu damit wird so weit wie möglich
kommen und natürlich wir werden in
dieser zeit noch ein paar
vorsichtsregeln beachten müssen das gilt
für masken in bahnen und bussen das gilt
selbstverständlich auch darauf hin dass
wir in ein restaurant geht oder in eine
bestimmte einrichtung genesen geimpft
oder getestet sein muss alles zumutbare
beschränkung die sind keine
unvertretbaren und und rechts
einschränkungen wie die afg uns immer
sei es sind die maßnahmen zur sicherheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger und sie
werden zusammen mit dem impf uns durch
diese krise merkt
dass wir so weit gekommen sind und dass
wir auch gesundheitlich und ökonomisch
durch die krise gekommen sind das hat
etwas damit zu tun dass wir
zusammengehalten haben dass wir sehr
viele mittel eingesetzt haben damit die
deutsche wirtschaft durch diese
schwierige situation kommt grundlage
dafür ist eine leistungsfähige weltweit
leistungsfähige volkswirtschaft
grundlage ist das für den letzten jahren
gut gehaushaltet haben und deshalb war
es richtig dass wir so viele mittel
eingesetzt haben um arbeitsplätze und
unternehmen in dieser krise zu retten
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir mit
diesem großen einsatz jetzt sehen der
aufschwung kommt wir wachsen aus der
krise raus aber deshalb ist auch klar zu
sagen wir werden mit dem wachstum die
finanziellen verpflichtungen die aus
dieser krise erwachsen sind auch wieder
bewältigen können das ist uns nach der
letzten wirtschaftskrise gelungen das
wird uns nach dieser wieder gewonnen
wachstum ist das entscheidende aber was
nicht funktioniert das will ich gerne
ausdrücklich sagen ist jetzt wenn in
dieser situation einige in diesem haus
vorschlagen dass leute die so viel
verdienen wie ein bundesminister oder
ein bundestagsabgeordneter oder noch
noch noch viel mehr dringend mal eine
steuersenkung brauchen 30 milliarden
euro steuersenkung die sie vorschlagen
für spitzenverdiener und unternehmen mit
riesigen gewinn sind in dieser situation
unfinanzierbar und völlig aus der zeit
gefallen und kein beweis für den
zusammenhalt dieser gesellschaft
das hofft man also anders machen wenn
wir zusammenhalten wollen so wie wir es
jetzt auch tun bei der bekämpfung der
folgen der flut die uns in den letzten
tagen so sehr bedrückt hat das ist eine
große herausforderung für unser land und
auch dort gilt wieder die eine
erkenntnis die für unsere gute zukunft
wichtig ist wir werden solche krisen und
herausforderungen nur bewältigen können
wenn wir zusammenhalten wenn wir das
gemeinsam durchstehen wollen wenn
niemand mit seinen problemen alleine
gelassen wird jetzt nicht die bürgern
und bürger deren häuser zerstört worden
sind jetzt nicht die dörfer und städte
die zerstört worden sind jetzt nicht die
länder die aldi infrastrukturen wieder
aufbauen müssen wir müssen als land
zusammenhalten wir tun das und ist
richtig dass der bundestag dazu die
notwendigen mittel jetzt bewilligt
zusammenhalt das ist auch das was wir im
blick haben müssen wenn wir über die
zukunft unserer gesellschaft diskutieren
und deshalb will ich über drei garantien
reden die mir ganz ganz wichtig sind für
den zusammenhalt den wir hier zu lande
brauchen die erste garantie ist eine die
für die jungen leute wichtig ist für die
kinder für diejenigen die hier
aufwachsen ich finde in einem so reichen
land wie deutschland darf es nicht so
sein dass kinder in armut aufwachsen wir
müssen etwas tun um sie für eine gute
zukunft zu unterstützen deshalb setze
ich mich dafür ein dass wir das
kindergeld weiterentwickeln dass wir
eine grundsicherung bekommt die armut
für kinder verhindert das muss in der
nächsten legislaturperiode gelingen
und wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass
sie gut aufwachsen können deshalb war
das richtig dass wir den weg
eingeschlagen haben mit dem gute kita
gesetz deshalb war es richtig dass wir
den ausbau der kinderbetreuung
vorangetrieben haben und deshalb ist es
richtig dass wir jetzt vier jahre darum
gestritten haben und heute ist
hoffentlich vollenden dass es auch
ganztagsangebote in den schulen gibt
deutschland muss ein land werden das
besser ist zu seinen kindern mit einer
guten kinderbetreuung mit einem
ganztagsangebot in den schulen und das
ist etwas was wir gemeinsam erreichen
müssen bund länder und gemeinden
zusammen
wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass die
jungen leute berufliche perspektiven
haben und deshalb ist es wichtig dass
wir dafür sorgen dass diejenigen die
studieren wollen bessere möglichkeiten
haben mit einer besseren
ausbildungsförderung aber noch viel
wichtiger ist dass wir uns um die
wichtigste ausbildung in deutschland
kümmern das ist nämlich unverändert die
berufsausbildung wir müssen dafür sorge
tragen dass jeder der nach der neunten
oder zehnten klasse die schule verlässt
auch eine gute perspektive auch in der
ausbildung hat eine garantie einen
ausstellungsplatz zu finden das ist das
wofür ich mich einsetzen
die zweite frage die für uns so wichtig
ist ist kann man sich das leben leisten
und deshalb ganz viel zu tun mit der
frage ob man eine wohnung findet die man
bezahlen kann oder ob der traum vieler
aufgeht die lange gespart haben um sich
ein kleines häuschen zu kaufen alles das
sind aufgaben für die wir uns als
gesellschaft als politik als gemeinwesen
einsetzen müssen und die tatsache dass
es in deutschland nicht genug wohnung
gibt die tatsache dass es so ist dass
die wohnungsmieten durch die decke
schießen das hat etwas damit zu tun dass
in den letzten jahren in deutschland
nicht gebaut worden genug gebaut worden
ist und wir müssen dafür sorge tragen
dass mehr wohnungen in deutschland
errichtet werden
ich habe mir das angeschaut
1973 sind in deutschland 800 1000
wohnungen gebaut worden
700.000 im westen deutschlands
hunderttausende mussten und wir sind
gerade bei 300.000 deshalb will ich
erreichen dass wir jedes jahr jahr für
jahr ohne damit aufzuhören
400.000 wohnungen bauen und 100.000
geförderte wohnungen damit auch
diejenigen mit wenig geld sich einen
briten
und weil das nicht auch von einem tag
auf den anderen geht weil das eine
anstrengende und viele viele jahre die
ganze zeit des nächsten jahrzehnts
beschäftigen wird sage ich ausdrücklich
wir müssen zwischendurch auch dafür
sorgen dass die mieten nicht durch die
decke schießen weil es zu wenig
wohnungen gibt und deshalb brauchen wir
ein starkes mieterschutz rechter
brauchen wir eine begrenzung der pid
preissteigerung bei neuvermietung und
deshalb brauchen wir ein moratorium für
den mietpreis und studie in deutschland
und das dritte das dritte was die
bürgerinnen bürger als garantie haben
wollen was wo sie eine aussage zu
verdient haben wo sie eine aussage
verlangen das ist die frage was ist
eigentlich mit der rente und ich will
das ausdrücklich ansprechen weil es ein
thema ist dass das ganze land betrifft
und nicht nur wie einige immer sagen die
älteren die jetzt in rente sind oder
diejenigen die demnächst in rente gehen
das ist ein thema für die jungen leute
wer jetzt mit 17 die schule verlässt und
eine berufsausbildung beginnt derjenige
oder diejenige hat fünf jahrzehnte
arbeit vor sich die ganze zeit müssen
beiträge gezahlt werden und in der
ganzen zeit muss er oder sie sich darauf
verlassen können dass das hinterher auch
etwas bringt für die rente deshalb
müssen klare aussagen her kein anstieg
des renteneintrittsalters und ein
stabiles rentenniveau das muss unsere
gesellschaft den bürgern und bürgern
dieses landes garantieren
das geht auch das geht auch und ich will
gerne sagen dass ich sehr aufgeregt und
empörten wenn all die experten experten
die uns in den 90er jahren so viele
dinge gesagt haben sich jetzt wieder
melden sie haben uns damals gesagt wir
würden jetzt zu dieser zeit viel höhere
beiträge zahlen als für jetzt zahlen und
sie haben uns damals gesagt es würde
jetzt vielmehr weniger arbeitnehmern
arbeitnehmer geben als zu der zeit
tatsächlich zahlen wir geringere
beiträge zur rentenversicherung als
zurzeit von helmut kohl und tatsächlich
ist es so dass millionen zusätzliche
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmer den
arbeitskraft ihrer arbeitskräfte
einsetzten geld verdienen und auch die
rentenfinanzen stabilisieren das ist die
wahrheit
und weil das die wahrheit ist
muss man auch sehr klar sagen da hätten
sich einige vielleicht mal zu melden und
zu sagen wir haben uns verrechnet unsere
vorhersagen stimmten nicht stattdessen
melden sie sich jetzt wieder und sagen
das gleiche was sie in den 90er jahren
gesagt haben dabei muss die antwort doch
klar sein es geht um beschäftigung wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass wir ein hohes
beschäftigungsniveau in deutschland
haben und wenn es uns gelänge auch nur
besser zu werden so wie wir das deshalb
zu werden indem der art und weise wie
das in schweden der fall ist was
frauenerwerbstätigkeit betrifft dann
hätten wir schon stabile renten und wenn
es uns gelingen würde das eine
55-jährige oder ein 58-jähriger die
ihren arbeitsplatz verlieren sicher
annehmen können dass sie erneut eine
gute beschäftigung finden würden dann
hätten wir stabile und das ist die
aufgabe die wir anpacken
herr minister die kollegen von storch
würdigen zwischenfragen stellen
gestatten sie es
[Applaus]
also
es gibt zwischen interventionen die
glaube ich bringen unsere debatte voran
und andere bei denen man sicher
vorhersagen kann wird wohl nicht so sein
wir haben also die chance dass wir das
hinkriegen mit unseren rennen und mit
den rentenfinanzen wenn wir das als
gesamtes land solidarisch angehen und
ich finde deshalb ist das eine wichtige
aussage die viele verdient haben ich
jedenfalls werde mich dafür einsetzen
dass wir diese drei garantien für unsere
zukunft geben und dann müssen wir uns
den beiden großen herausforderungen
zuwenden die jetzt vor uns liegen wenn
wir uns auf die zwanziger jahre zu
bewegen die jetzt begonnen haben die
nächsten zehn jahre werden entscheidend
sein für die zukunft unseres landes die
weichen die wir jetzt falsch stellen die
wenn dazu führen dass wir nicht es
schaffen die großen herausforderung zu
bewältigen wenn wir es falsch machen
kann uns dass wohlstand und
arbeitsplätze kosten wenn wir es richtig
machen werden wir eine bessere zukunft
haben und deshalb zwei dinge die mir da
wichtig sind die eine große
herausforderung ist ich möchte gerne
dafür sorge tragen dass in dieser
gesellschaft mehr respekt herrscht der
respekt vor jedem und vor jeder ich will
dafür sorge tragen dass jede berufliche
leistung jede lebensleistung anerkannt
wird und für mich hat das etwas damit zu
tun dass anerkennung gilt auch für die
leistung die jetzt in dieser krise
erneut als systemrelevant erkannt worden
sind und deshalb will ich ihnen das
sagen die lebensmittel verkäuferin der
paketbote die altenpflegerin der
krankenpflege und viele weitere haben in
dieser krise zurecht anerkennung
bekommen und beifall erhalten das muss
aber auch nach der krise noch ein
prinzip unseres landes sein
und auch das gilt anerkennung ist
wichtig aber es geht immer auch ums geld
und deshalb finde ich kann es nicht
dabei bleiben dass diejenigen die jetzt
den beifall bekommen haben weiter
schlecht bezahlt werden in diesem land
darum setze ich mich dafür ein dass wir
im ersten jahr der neuen regierung den
mindestlohn auf 12 euro erhöhen das ist
eine gehaltserhöhung für zehn millionen
arbeitnehmer in deutschland
10 millionen
das heißt ja übersetzt auch das sind
sehr sehr viele und das sagt etwas über
das gehaltsniveau in diesem lande und
das sagt warum die forderung so
wichtiges für ein gutes miteinander in
unserer gesellschaft für mich bedeutet
das aber auch dass wir uns nicht auf
mindestlöhne beschränken dürfen sondern
auch an anderer stelle dafür sorgen
müssen dass es besser läuft so wie wir
das jetzt in vielen anläufen hingekriegt
haben dass endlich in der
fleischindustrie normale arbeitsverträge
abgeschlossen werden das war lange
überfällig wir haben es durchgesetzt
meine damen und herren
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir uns in
vielen anläufen darum bemüht haben dass
endlich in der altenpflege besser
gezahlt wird und dass wir es jetzt
hingekriegt haben ein gesetz zu
beschließen dem drin steht ab dem
nächsten sommer dürfen
pflegeeinrichtungen nur gemäß tarif
bezahlen wenn sie bei der kasse
abrechnen wollen das ist ein erster
schritt dem viele weitere folgen müssen
für diese arbeit
die zweite große herausforderung die wir
in unserer gesellschaft bewältigt müssen
wenn wir an die 20er jahre denken das
ist aber auch die aufgabe dafür zu
sorgen dass wir in zehn 20 und 30 jahren
noch gute arbeitsplätze haben viele
bürgerinnen bürger sind sich nicht so
sicher ob das wohl so ausgehen wird sie
haben sorge und sie schauen sich ein um
wenn der welt und stellen fest dass
anders als vor vielen jahrzehnten ist
doch so ist das auf dieser welt vielen
ähnliches können wie wir es sind
milliarden im wieder aufgestiegen asien
es werden viele seinen afrika und dem
süden amerikas was gutes für die welt
aber was ja die anforderung für uns und
unser land richtig formuliert wir müssen
technologisch da vorne bei sein wir
müssen vorne anstehen wenn es darum geht
wirtschaftlich an der spitze mit auf dem
weltmarkt tätig zu sein und dafür müssen
wir uns jetzt einsetzen wir brauchen
technologischen fortschritt für
deutschland und eine leistungsfähige
industrie auch in der zukunft
gute arbeitsplätze gute arbeitsplätze
hier wird es aber nur geben wenn wir
gleichzeitig schaffen den
menschengemachten klimawandel
aufzuhalten
und das ist für mich die ganz große
herausforderung vor der wir stehen und
bei der wir jetzt die notwendigen
entscheidungen treffen müssen wir haben
uns entschieden über den einstieg in die
erneuerbaren energien mit einem gesetz
das aus den anfang dieses jahrtausends
start wir haben uns entschieden die
grundvoraussetzung dafür zu schaffen
dass die atomenergie nicht mehr genutzt
werden kann und sie steigende steigen
aus dem nächsten jahr wir steigen aus
der kohleverstromung aus wir wollen den
knapp 25 jahren klimaneutral
wirtschaften das ist eine ehrgeizige
herausforderung wenn man bedenkt dass
250 jahre industriegeschichte darauf
beruhen dass wir kohle gas und öl
einsetzen und deshalb sage ich das darf
man nicht unterschätzen aber weil es
eine so große aufgabe ist und weil wir
sie schaffen können hier in deutschland
müssen sie jetzt anpacken und jetzt die
notwendigen entscheidungen treffen
zu diesen entscheidungen zu diesen
entscheidungen gehört aber auch dass wir
sagen was wir dazu brauchen
denn als alternative für die weg gegen
die nutzung der atomenergie als
alternative für die ausbleibende nutzung
der kohleverstromung werden wir
zusätzlichen strom aus erneuerbaren
quellen aus windkraft auf hoher see an
land und der sonne nutzen müssen aber
für das was die industrie vor hat
brauchen wir noch viel mehr strom wer am
er spricht mit der stahlindustrie wer
spricht mit der chemie industrie
wer spricht mit denen die zement
herstellen er spricht mit der
automobilindustrie den zulieferern mit
dem maschinenbau mit all den industrien
und wirtschaftszweigen die in
deutschland so wichtig sind der weiß
dass sie dass sie einen klaren plan
haben was zu tun ist dass sie
milliardenschwere investitionen vorhaben
dass sie genau wissen wie sie das
hinkriegen klimaneutral zu wirtschaften
das ist der unterschied zu ihnen die
industrie weiß mehr als sie von der afg
die weiß wieder weg geht
aber
aber sie sagen was wir dazu brauchen ist
strom strom aus windkraft aus sonne
wasserstoff und ein leistungsfähiges
stromnetz und deshalb müssen wir die
ausbauziele hoch setzen die
chemieindustrie hat uns gesagt sie wird
2050 so viel strom verbrauchen wie
deutschland heute insgesamt die
stahlindustrie braucht entsprechend mehr
strom alles aus windkraft sonne und bei
der nutzung von wasserstoff und das ist
die aufgabe die wir jetzt zustande
bringen müssen indem wir jetzt die
ausbauziele für 2045 festlegen indem wir
jetzt festlegen dass wir entsprechend
das stromnetz ertüchtigen und in dem wir
alle gesetze ändern im nächsten jahr
damit die dinge rechtzeitig fertig
werden können eine windkraftanlage zu
genehmigen deutschland darf nicht mehr
sechs jahre dauern das muss in sechs
monaten gehen meine damen und herren
klimaschutz das ist jetzt industrie
politik und deshalb muss es darum gehen
dass wir mit der industrie zusammen
diese große herausforderung bewältigen
klimaschutz ist auch eine politik die
die industrie will sie hat die pläne sie
weiß wie das geht wir müssen unseren
beitrag dazu leisten damit das
funktioniert und deshalb bin ich dafür
dass wir diese große aufgabe anpacken es
ist wichtig für den wohlstand unseres
landes und die zukunft der
bundesrepublik deutschland
vielleicht noch eine bemerkung die ja
immer auf einen einwand der immer kommt
zum beispiel aus ihren reihen aber auch
von anderen da wird gesagt was bringt
das wenn wir das hier in deutschland
machen wir sind ja nur ein kleiner teil
der welt und wenn wir das hier machen
dann hat das ja gar keine auswirkung auf
andere orte der welt das ist aber falsch
denn
natürlich werden wir niemals
die länder asiens afrikas und im süden
amerika davon abbringen können den
gleichen wohlstand haben zu wollen wie
wir das s steht hinzu und sie tun alles
dafür dass ihnen das möglich ist aber
was wir können mit unseren ingenieuren
und ingenieuren mit unserer industrie
mit unserer wirtschaftskraft die
technologien entwickeln die für die
ganze welt eine alternative sind zu den
fossilen ressourcen die heute genutzt
werden und genau diese aufgabe müssen
wir es an
weil wir diese debatte ja ab und zu auch
sehr freundlich zueinander sind möchte
ich dass an dieser stelle sagen die
tatsache dass die cdu csu in den letzten
jahren jedes jahr wieder den ausbau der
stromerzeugung kapazitäten abgelehnt hat
weil sie der festen überzeugung war dass
das falsch ist dass das nicht gebrauchte
dass sie noch vor zwei jahren gesagt hat
man braucht nicht mehr strom dass sie
noch im letzten jahr gesagt hat man
braucht nicht mehr strom dass sie noch
im juni gesagt hat man braucht nicht
mehr strom das ist eine bedrohung für
den wirtschaftsstandort deutschland eine
weitere von der cdu csu geführte
bundesregierung würde deutschland
wohlstand und arbeitsplätze kosten
meine damen und herren wir
brauchen respekt in unserer gesellschaft
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die zukunft
uns gelingt dass die 20er jahre ein
aufbruch werden die sicherstellen dass
wir in zehn 20 30 jahren noch gute
arbeitsplätze haben und dass wir den
menschengemachten klimawandel aufhalten
können aber wir müssen auch gut
verstehen dass wir nicht alleine sind
auf der welt sondern dass wir nur
gemeinsam mit unseren freundinnen und
freunden in europa eine perspektive
haben in der künftigen welt gut zurecht
kommen zu können das zu verteidigen was
uns wichtig ist an rechtsstaatlichkeit
an demokratie an sozialer
marktwirtschaft und deshalb will ich
hier an dieser stelle noch einmal
bekennen ein weiterer fortschritt für
europa ist das wichtigste nationale
anliegen dass wir in deutschland haben
nur mit der europäischen union gemeinsam
werden wir in einer welt die um die
mitte dieses jahrhunderts zehn
milliarden einwohner hat noch relevant
seien noch mitbestimmen können noch
entscheiden können wie unser leben sich
entwickeln soll und darum muss
deutschland die aufgabe wahrnehmen dafür
zu sorgen dass die europäische union
gelingt und wir eine bessere europäische
union bekommen
deutschland ist das große land in der
mitte der europäischen union wir sind
die die nicht am rande stehen können
schlecht gelaunte kommentare zu den
plänen der anderen abgeben und irgendwie
letztendlich das spiel spielen dass man
hierzulande den fernsehkameras mitteilt
was man alles in brüssel erreichen will
dort freundlich verhandelt hinterher
zurück geht und sagt wie man es allen
anderen gezeigt hat wir müssen das
anders machen wir müssen das land sein
das sich verantwortlich fühlt für diesen
gemeinsamen fortschritt und auch
verhindert dass es eine spaltung gibt
zwischen nord und süd und west und ost
in europa sondern dass die weitere
integration europas gelingt das ist die
große herausforderung das ist die große
aufgabe die wir haben und das wollen wir
gemeinsam hinkriegen die bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes dieser deutsche
bundestag und die künftige
bundesregierung
aber auch wenn europa das ist woran wir
arbeiten müssen ein starkes souveränes
europa das in der lage ist die eigenen
angelegenheiten in die hand zu nehmen
wird es nur gelingen im verbund
der nato und in enger zusammenarbeit mit
den vereinigten staaten von amerika der
transatlantischen zusammenarbeit die so
unverzichtbar ist das geld und das gilt
auch in zukunft und für mich bedeutet
das auch dass wir alles dafür tun müssen
dass wir unsere
verteidigungsanstrengungen auch gut
gewährleisten können deshalb bin ich
froh dass in dieser legislaturperiode
die schlechte zeit für die bundeswehr
begonnen hat bei einer schwarz gelben
koalition es tut mir leid das sagen zu
müssen dass die endlich zu ende gegangen
ist dass der bundeswehr haushalt die
größten steigerung in den letzten jahren
gekriegt hat das war richtig so und
diesen weg werden wir weiter beschreiten
meine damen tragen
wir werden auch in zukunft das will ich
an dieser stelle sagen
weiter entscheidung treffen müssen im
rahmen der eröffnung im rahmen der nato
mit auf grundlage von entscheiden der
vereinten nationen dass wir soldaten im
ausland einsetzen und ich finde dass die
entwicklung in afghanistan ein anlass
dafür gibt jeweils zu diskutieren was
man macht und was richtig ist aber es
muss dabei bleiben dass wir verstehen
dass wir nicht alleine sind sondern dass
wir mit den anderen zusammen für frieden
und sicherheit in der welt sorgen müssen
und das wird auch in zukunft weiter eine
aufgabe sein
in dem sinne haben
wir jetzt die letzte debatte in diesem
haus heute die letzten debatten ich bin
sehr dankbar dass wir hier so
miteinander diskutieren können denn
jetzt ist ja die zeit der bürgerinnen
und bürger sie entscheiden am 26
september wie es weitergeht mit diesem
land sie entscheiden wie es weitergeht
mit unserer gesellschaft auf respekt sie
bewegt ob wir eine gute zukunft haben ob
wir ein starkes und souveränes europa
haben die bürgerinnen und bürger haben
jetzt das wort ein aufbruch ist möglich
und ich hoffe und ich bin sicher er wird
gelingt schönen dank
olaf scholz gibt sich bundes guter
umfragewerte hier im bundestag
staatsmännisch nicht wirklich aggressiv
ganz im gegenteil er dankt angela merkel
für die gute zusammenarbeit und lobte
die arbeit der großen koalition zusammen
halt ein wort das immer wieder betont
wachstum beschäftigung bieten rente und
klimaschutz seiner hauptthemen es folgt
nun als nächster redner christian
lindner der partei und
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
[Musik]
jetzt hat das wort im
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp christian
lindner
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
der kanzlerkandidat
eine gewisse siegesgewissheit kann man
ihnen nicht absprechen
allerdings geht es nicht darum umfragen
zu gewinnen sondern wahlen
und 1900
und
1976 hat helmut kohl sogar die erfahrung
machen müssen dass man wahlen gewinnen
kann und danach trotzdem keine koalition
hat
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben
entschieden hier noch einmal zu reden
sie haben über die leistungen ihrer
kanzlerschaft gesprochen 16 jahre dem
land an vorderster stelle zu dienen das
hat unser aller respekt verdient dennoch
muss man feststellen
am ende ihrer kanzlerschaft ist unser
land nicht in der verfassung
die unseren ansprüchen genügen sollten
vor vier jahren hieß es ein deutschland
in dem wir gut und gerne leben heute
wäre kontinuität das größte risiko für
unser land denn so wie es ist doch erst
nicht wahr
drei krisen corona die flutkatastrophe
und der chaotische abzug aus afghanistan
haben uns allen in diesem sommer noch
einmal vor augen geführt wo die defizite
liegen manche erfinden ja gerne zumal in
wahlkämpfen neue aufgaben für unseren
staat
aber unser staat hat schon viele
aufgaben
bundeswehr bildung digitale
infrastruktur und verwaltung justiz
katastrophenschutz und polizei
statt fortwährend neue aufgaben für
diesen staat zu erfinden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sollten wir uns
der staatsaufgaben nummer eins widmen
nämlich wieder funktionieren
die herausforderungen vor denen wir
stehen sind zweifellos groß dringlich
ist dass wir schnellstmöglich in der
pandemie zu einem gesellschaftlichen
normalzustand zurückkehren wie tests und
hygiene konzepten haben wir zum einen
instrumente an der hand zum anderen aber
brauchen wir schnell fortschritte bei
den impfungen wo sind die mobilen im
teams überdies so intensiv gesprochen
wird auf dem campus der universität in
den stadtteilen vor den einkaufszentren
bei sport und
kulturveranstaltungen nicht mehr die
menschen sollten zum impfstoff gehen der
impfstoff muss jetzt zu den menschen
kommen einmal muss es gelingen
einmal muss es doch gelingen dass wir
wort wörtlich vor die welle kommen wir
brauchen nämlich eine politische
garantie dass es in diesem herbst eben
nicht noch einmal zur pauschalen
freiheits einschränkungen nicht noch
einmal zu einem auch nur teilweisen
lockdown kommen der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat unlängst
in einer zeit und gesagt erfordere die
menschen auf nur noch kurz bis zum
frühjahr durchzuhalten ich glaube es ist
die verantwortung der politik dass wir
in diesem herbst schon wieder
gesellschaftliches leben für alle
garantiert
der pandemie müssen wir die erholung der
wirtschaft organisieren die
staatsfinanzen müssen stabilisiert
werden wir müssen tempo machen bei der
digitalisierung um unser land
international konkurrenzfähig zu halten
der demografische wandel macht einer um
eine umstellung unserer sozialsysteme
notwendig und im kampf gegen den
klimawandel
unseren charakter als industrie nation
zu erhalten das wird die aufgabe dieses
jahrzehnts sein wenn der kanzlerkandidat
der cdu sagt vor uns stünde ein
erneuerungs eine modernisierungs
jahrzehnt dann hat er recht aber was für
ein trauriges zeugnis stellt er damit
zugleich seiner eigenen partei aus die
16 jahre dieses land regiert wird und
dennoch und dennoch schauen wir nicht
mit pessimismus in die zukunft ganz im
gegenteil wir sind zutiefst davon
überzeugt dass wir diese
herausforderungen nicht nur bewältigen
können sondern dass in ohne ihnen
chancen liegen wir können sie nicht nur
bewältigen wir können sie zu einem
fortschritt thema unseres landes machen
die kassandra rufer der afg haben
unrecht wenn sie fortwährend die
abstiegs geschichte deutschlands bemühen
dieses land hat unglaublich viel private
initiative dieses land hat unglaublich
viel privates know how dieses land hat
sogar unglaublich viel privates kapital
das problem ist nicht das land das
problem ist eine regierung die dieses
land fortwährend unterfordert und
bürokratisch hessels
der kanzlerkandidat scholz hat hier eben
eine reihe von garantien gegeben
ökologische und soziale vorhaben
vorgestellt davon hört man viel auch in
diesen wochen von allen politischen
akteuren und ja auch wir als fraktion
der freien demokraten haben soziale und
ökologische vorhaben da wollen wir uns
von niemandem übertroffen übertreffen
lassen und trotzdem herr scholz haben
sie in ihrer sehr umfänglichen rede nur
kursorisch die grundlage jeder sozialen
und ökologischen politik angesprochen
die grundlage nämlich für alle sozialen
und ökologischen ziele die auch sie hier
vorgestellt haben ist ein stabiles
wirtschaftliches fundament ohne eine
starke wirtschaft ist alles was sie auch
an zusagen gegeben haben eine
unrealisierbar
unfinanzierbare träumerei und deshalb
dürfen wir nicht mehr nur wahlkämpfe mit
mit dem versprechen der ausstellung von
staatlichen leistungen subventionen und
andere machen sondern wir müssen uns
auch der frage stellen wie dieses land
diese herausforderungen bewältigen kann
wie wir unser wirtschaftliches fundament
stärken sie haben gerade gesagt herr
scholz wir wachsen heraus aus der krise
tatsächlich hatte deutschland im zweiten
quartal 1,5 prozent wachstum aber ist
das tatsächlich die dimension die wir
zur sicherung unseres wohlstands
benötigen für deutschland insgesamt wird
dieses jahr 3,4 prozent wachstum
prognostiziert
für die vereinigten staaten von amerika
in dessen sind es sieben für china 8,1
selbst italien wird mit 4,2 prozent
wachstum eine dynamischere wirtschaft
haben als wir das ist keine statistische
größe das ist eine reale geht es sagt
nicht die opposition es sagen die zahlen
unser land kommt schlechter aus der
krise als die wettbewerber und das zeigt
dass deutschland in den vergangenen
jahren dramatisch an
wettbewerbsfähigkeit verloren hat und
dass meine damen und herren bedeutet
übersetzt millionen von bürgerinnen und
bürger haben schlechtere chancen auf
sozialen aufstieg als anderswo in europa
und der welt und aus diesem grund
aus diesem grund kann und darf sich die
politik nicht länger mehr nur auf das
verteilen des wohlstands konzentrieren
da gibt es ja spezialisten dafür die
sich ausschließlich auf dass verteilung
des wohlstands konzentrieren dieses land
muss aber die frage neu beantworten wie
es diesen wohlstand unter veränderten
bedingungen überhaupt erwirtschaften
wird deshalb braucht unsere wirtschaft
deshalb braucht unsere wirtschaft einen
kickstart aus der krise wir müssen zur
spitze in der welt aufschließen aber
nicht mit bürokratischen subventionen
oder staatlich gelenkten
konjunkturprogrammen sondern ich mag
wirtschaftliche impulse herr scholz sie
haben hier heute gesprochen über
diejenigen die über steuerentlastungen
sprechen sie haben tatsächlich in einem
höchst steuer land diejenigen hier
kritisiert die entlastung organisieren
wollen sie selbst haben aber geschwiegen
darüber dass ihre fraktion und
diejenigen die ihnen politisch
nahestehen in diesem land bereits
flächige steuererhöhungen organisieren
wollen nach einer wirtschaftskrise
wollen sie für den mittelstand für den
ja auch die einkommenssteuer die
betriebliche steuer ist nach einer krise
in denen viele eigenkapital verloren
haben nach einer krise indem
selbständige die altersversorgung haben
an greifen wollen nach einer solchen
wirtschaftskrise wollen sie allen
ernstes einen aufschwung mit
steuererhöhungen organisieren ich sage
ihnen das glatte gegenteil wäre richtig
auf eine wirtschaftskrise antwortet man
mit entlastungen
ein beispiel ein beispiel ich will
ich will ich will ganz sicher nicht in
jedem punkt auf die britische politik
bezug nehmen aber tatsächlich hat die
regierung im vereinigten königreich nun
ein super abschreibungs programm
vorgelegt
130 prozent abschreibung auf
investitionen im ersten jahr das müssen
wir in deutschland nicht eins zu eins
übernehmen denn so investitions
zurückhaltend die die britische
wirtschaft sind der deutsche mittelstand
und die deutsche industrie nicht aber
trotzdem sollten wir uns daran
orientieren der konkrete vorschlag ist
wir brauchen in deutschland ebenfalls
super abschreibungen geben wir den
betrieben eine phase in der es in der
sie hohe investitionen in die anlagen
binnen zwei jahren abschreiben können so
mobilisieren wir private investitionen
in saubere technologien in investitionen
für den klimaschutz die digitalisierung
die modernisierung unseres landes und
sorgen wir mit einer pause für
zusätzliche bürokratie anna lieferketten
gesetzt dafür dass die betriebe sich auf
das konzentrieren können was jetzt not
tut nämlich die sicherung und die
schaffung von jobs
zur
ökonomischen transformation gehört ist
ja auch die ökologische transformation
mitzudenken wir müssen allerdings klären
in welche richtung wir uns entwickeln
wollen hier in berlin sprechen sprechen
die grünen ja davon sie wollen aus
unserer hauptstadt ein bullerbü machen
ich habe mitunter den eindruck dass
bullerbü auch ihr leitbild sein könnte
für die zukunft unseres
industriestandorts eine ländliche
dorfidylle mit subventionierten
lastenfahrrad aber bei aller liebe bei
aller liebe zu astrid lindgren und bobby
ich kann mich nicht erinnern jemals
gelesen zu haben wovon die eigentlichen
bilder bobby leben und deshalb kann das
kein leitbild kann das kein leitbild für
deutschland sein aber wir können den
klimaschutz vorreiter sein wir müssen es
sogar wir können zeigen dass klimaschutz
nichts belasten das ist die schweiz ist
ein mahnendes beispiel in der schweiz
hat selbst eine jüngere generation sich
gegen ein klimagesetz ausgesprochen
deshalb weil sie das gefühl hatten in
ihrer freien lebensführung und in ihren
wirtschaftlichen perspektiven
beschnitten zu werten und genau das
sollte uns auch eine eine mahnung sein
der führende und einer der führenden
deutschen intellektuellen heinz budde
hat neulich in der ihnen nahe stehenden
tageszeitung taz ein interview gegeben
und bude sagt zitat ich empfehle dem
grünen milieu eine
nähere beschäftigung mit der fdp denn
angesichts des klimaschutzes droht das
individuum unter die räder zu geraten
und hans bruder hat recht mit der art
und weise wie sie klimaschutz
vorschlagen gerät das individuum mit
seinem recht auf freiheit und
wirtschaftliche perspektive unter die
räder
machen wir uns ehrlich die frankfurter
allgemeine zeitung die fast einmal nicht
die taz schrieb neulich dass unsere
energie und klimapolitik inzwischen ein
labyrinth sei
von sich zum teil widersprechenden
geboten verboten subventionen anreizen
und programmen fahren wir in dieser
wichtigen aufgabe neu an geben wir ein
klares ziel vor null emissionen im
übernächsten jahrzehnt aber setzen wir
zur erreichung auf die marktwirtschaft
denn sie hat historisch und
international bewiesen dass sie im
umgang mit knappen ressourcen überlegen
ist im vergleich zu allen anderen
ordnungen und herr scholz sie haben
recht der strombedarf der deutschen
wirtschaft steigt aber nicht alleine nur
die kapazität der energieerzeugung ist
in deutschland entscheidend wir müssen
auch hier die frage nach der
bezahlbarkeit der energie stellen und
deshalb kann das erneuerbare energien
gesetz eben nicht so bleiben wie es ist
und deshalb war es richtig was in der
vergangenheit so viel lob an cdu und csu
bei den ausbauzielen auch auf den preis
geachtet wird das german engineered
klimaschutz funktioniert zeigt übrigens
nebenbei gesagt die iaa die deutsche
schlüsselindustrie hat sich längst für
ihre zukunftsaufgaben aufgestellt mit
innovativen und sauberen produkten
werden wir auch in zukunft das autoland
nummer 1 sein können und deshalb
brauchte diese industrie mit ihren
milliardengewinnen
auch nichts mehr die subventionen die
nahezu alle fraktionen dieses hauses
unverändert ins schaufenster stellen es
klar zu sagen es ist absurd dass der
deutsche steuerzahler
auch die e autos für gutverdiener über
den lebenszyklus mit bis zu
20.000 euro fördert während wir pro
schuljahr und schüler nur
1200 euro in die bildung investieren die
automobilbranche
die automobilbranche bei allem respekt
die braucht technologieoffenheit damit
zum beispiel auch synthetische
kraftstoffe als teil des energie imports
im markt eine chance haben aber die
automobilbranche braucht keine
geldgeschenke der steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler mehr
von einem weg also des verzichts und der
verbote raten wir ab
herr scholz hat ja darauf hingewiesen
dass auch er den wunsch nach prosperität
und wohlstand in anderen weltregionen
respektiert das teile ich aber eher
stolz wenn wir vorreiter sein wollen
dann sollten sie auch in das programm
ihrer partei und das von bündnis 90 die
grünen schauen in diesem programm ist
nämlich nicht davon die rede wir wollen
klimaschutz durch technologie machen
durch marktwirtschaft und fortschritt
sondern überwiegend finde ich auch in
ihrem programm die breite phalanx der
kleinteiligen eingriffe in das
wirtschaftliche und das
gesellschaftliche leben stichwort
tempolimit als ob zum beispiel ein
tempolimit einen beitrag zur bekämpfung
der erderwärmung leisten würde es ist
ausschließlich eine wertefrage es hat
keinen beitrag zur bekämpfung der
erderwärmung es ist nur die werte frage
ob man erwachsenen menschen mündige
entscheidungen verantwortliche
entscheidungen zutraut oder nicht mehr
ist das nicht mein vorschlag
mein vorschlag ist deshalb ein anderer
warum stellen wir solche kleinteiligen
reglementierungen nicht zur seite im
nächsten jahr wird deutschland den
vorsitz der g 20 partner in der g 7
haben wir werden die g7 präsidentschaft
haben machen wir doch das thema
klimaschutz durch technologie machen wir
doch globale partnerschaft beim
klimaschutz zum leitgedanken der
deutschen g7 präsidentschaft im nächsten
jahr wie ungleich größer wäre das als
die kleinteiligen debatte über
tempolimits in deutschland
schützen wir die handlungsfähigkeit der
nachfolgenden generation aber nicht nur
durch klimaschutz sondern auch durch
solides haushalten
nach corona stehen wir vor
rekordschulden doch liegt es wirklich an
der pandemie wenn man die finanzpolitik
von olaf scholz vor 2020 betrachtet
ergibt sich ein anderes bild denn die
staatsquote ist kontinuierlich gestiegen
2009 10 lag sie bei 45,2 prozent
angesichts von rekord steuereinnahmen
ist viel zu wenig eingesetzt worden für
schuldenabbau und konsolidierung die
bundesausgaben sind in den letzten
jahren doppelt so stark gestiegen wie
die realwirtschaft und zu viele
staatsausgaben sind in konsumtive
bereiche geflossen nicht in
investitionen es ist nicht die
schuldenbremse die uns gehindert hat an
investitionen es waren die politischen
leitentscheidungen für den staatskonsum
lediglich 3,9 prozent der milliarden
steuereinnahmen seit 2013 wir sind in
investitionen geflossen die unser land
moderner gemacht hätten fast 50 prozent
der steuer mehreinnahmen dagegen in den
staatlichen konsum der ehemalige
chefökonom des bmf ludger schuknecht auf
den hätten sie hören sollen der hat
nämlich von einer verdrängung der
investitionen durch den staatlichen
konsum im haushalt gesprochen und davor
gewarnt diese stimme der vernunft musste
auf entscheidung von olaf scholz das
finanzministerium verlassen und das ist
für mich ein deutlicher beleg nicht die
pandemie hat die staatsfinanzen ruiniert
das war zuvor schon die haushaltspolitik
von olaf scholz
die folgen expansive finanzpolitik sehen
wir allerdings schon heute die inflation
liegt bei 3,9 prozent so hoch wie seit
jahrzehnten nicht prognosen gehen von
einem anstieg auf 5 prozent aus und das
trifft kleiner und mittlerer einkommen
das trifft die rentnerinnen und rentner
denen kann man nicht empfehlen die
jüngeren geht in aktien für die ist es
aufgrund ihrer lebenssituation
möglicherweise gar nicht empfehlenswert
in langfristige anlage zu gehen die
natürlich auch in der kurzfristigen
betrachtung ein risiko haben wir haben
gerade die rentnerinnen und rentner die
kleinsparer die menschen mit kleinem
einkommen die werden durch inflation
getroffen selbstverständlich hat die
inflation etwas mit unterbrochenen
lieferketten und sondereffekten zu tun
aber was mir nicht aus den augen in
diesem zusammenhang die politik unsere
europäischen notenbank die ezb musste
aufgrund der enormen
verschuldungssituation in europa zu
künstlich niedrigen zinsen greifen zu
anleiheankaufprogramm sie hat deshalb
gar nicht mehr das instrumentarium wie
die amerikanische notenbank um auf die
inflation zu reagieren und deshalb armin
laschet der sagt erreicht mich mit dem
taschenrechner nach brüssel deshalb herr
scholz der sie hier von integration
sprechen erwarten wir ein klares
statement auch noch vor der
bundestagswahl das deutschland in der
nächsten legislaturperiode weiter ich
sage besser wieder anwalt von stabilität
in europa ist die finanzpolitische
eigenverantwortung der mitglieder der
wirtschafts und währungsunion muss unser
anliegen
machen wir die
sozialversicherungssysteme nachhaltig
der demografische wandel droht unsere
sozialkassen zu überfordern und
alimentierung mag edlen motiven folgen
nachhaltig ist sie nicht das gros der
menschen will eben nicht transfers
sondern faire chancen auf einen job und
deshalb muss das neue gesellschaftliche
politik projekt die erneuerung des
aufstiegs versprechens eine gute bildung
ist dazu der schlüssel
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass der eigene
wohlstand nicht durch das elternhaus
vorgezeichnet wird es ist zeit dass wir
bildung auch für den bund zu einem
schlüsselprojekt machen damit der bund
investieren darf in kitas schulen und
hochschulen dass wir eine
exzellenzinitiative bekommen nicht nur
für die hochschulen sondern für den
beruflichen bereich das
kooperationsverbot muss fallen und für
die menschen die trotz arbeitslosigkeit
in einer schweren lebenssituation
geraten muss es aufstiegschancen geben
herr scholz sie sprechen von 12 euro
mindestlohn wer einen minijob hat hat
dadurch kein höheres einkommen sondern
wird gezwungen weniger zu arbeiten das
allein hilft menschen nicht und wie
viele menschen im mindestlohn haben
einen minijob was ist mit der allein
erziehenden mutter im hartz-iv-bezug wir
wollen sie wenn sie ein minijob hat zwar
den mindestlohn erhören aber die
zuverdienstgrenzen die sind nicht erhöht
die wird weiter 80 prozent ihres
zuverdienst abgeben um das ist der
größte skandal der aufstiegs
gerechtigkeit in deutschland und deshalb
wir stehen vor richtungsentscheidungen
in diesem land unsere botschaft ist klar
freiheit vor staat erwirtschaften vor
verteilen und mehr freude am erfinden
als an verbieten
das war der spitzenkandidat der fdp
christian lindner der olaf scholz vor zu
viel siegesgewissheit warnt auch als
stärkste partei könne es passieren dass
eine regierungsbildung nicht klappe ein
klarer hinweis darauf dass die fdp
natürlich lieber in eine koalition mit
der million eintritt wird es in einer
ampel dass der urlaub scholz politik als
finanzminister kritisiert kein wunder
hinter selber will ja finanzminister in
einer neuen regierung werden nächster
redner gegner bartsch
in kürze endet ihre amtszeit nach 16
jahren nach beinahe sechs 1000 tagen an
der regierungsspitze nach unzähligen
reden verhandlungen entscheidungen
gipfel gipfel nächten sie haben sie
eingesetzt und haben sich selbst viel
abverlangt das erkennt meine fraktion
auch an ich sage aber auch nach 16
jahren kanzlerschaft nach fast 6000
tagen unter ihrer führung mit spd oder
fdp braucht unser land dringend einen
regierungswechsel ich stimme ihm zu es
geht um einrichtungen
das land ist heute
sozial kulturell politisch tiefer
gespalten als zu binden ihrer
kanzlerschaft sie hinterlassen ein land
im krisen zustand und nicht wenige
bürgerinnen und bürger die das vertrauen
in die staatliche kompetenz der
krisenlösung immer mehr verliebt
verlieren wir kolleginnen und kollegen
krisen werden nicht mehr gelöst sondern
sie werden verwaltet ministerinnen und
minister wären nichts an ihrer leistung
gemessen sondern durchgeschleppt bis zum
schluss eingeschlichen hat sie in 16
jahren eine unkultur der politischen
verantwortungslosigkeit meine damen und
herren und das muss keine werden
die bewegung verlegen 16 jahren an der
spitze eines landes das ist ja die
gelegenheit ein land zu prägen und ein
politisches vermächtnis zu hinterlassen
ich habe genau zugehört was das sein
soll hat ja vielleicht ein
zukunftsfähiger sozialstaat oder
ähnliches sein können sie haben über
digitalisierung gesprochen dass das so
toll ist ich kann nur sagen schon vor 16
jahren wurde gesagt deutschland soll
weltmeister bei der digitalisierung
seine wie ist die realität wir sind
hinteren drittel meine damen und herren
gucke ich doch die schulen an bei der
digitalisierung war das ist eines der
grössten skandale und ich will ihnen
sagen was bleibt unser land hat sich
auseinander entwickelt und will ihnen
ein beispiel sagen 2006 lebten 18,6
prozent der kinder unter der
armutsgrenze und im jahre 2019 sind das
20,5 prozent die kinderarmut in unserem
land ist gestiegen 2020 leben fast zwei
millionen minderjährige in hartz4
familie das ist ihre bilanz und ich
filme auf ihren eigenen um an ihren
maßstäben das zu messen in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag steht auf seite 21 wir
werden kinderrechte im grundgesetz
ausdrücklich verankern kinder sind
grundrechtsträger ihre rechte haben für
uns verfassungsrang was haben sie
gemacht gar nichts haben sie gemacht das
zeigt die wertschätzung der kinder der
heranwachsenden unserem land und ich
finde das ist skandalös dass sie bei
kinderarmut bei den heranwachsenden so
versagt haben
die bundesregierung hat das vertrauen in
staatliche handlungsfähigkeit in
vorsorge und sicherheit extrem
eingeschränkt und die kolleginnen und
kollegen nach 18 monaten pandemie ist
eine frage überhaupt nicht geklärt ich
finde im übrigen dass es richtig war
dass geholfen worden ist ich finde auch
die neuverschuldung richtig da haben wir
vieles zu kritisieren gehabt an
einzelmaßnahmen aber kurzarbeitergeld
unterstützung von unternehmen und soweit
alles in ordnung aber die zentrale frage
wer zahlt die krise die wird nicht
beantwortet oder ich kann es auch ganz
anders fragen warum sollen diejenigen
die dieses land am laufen halten warum
sollen die krankenschwester der
paketbote der busfahrer die krone
rechnung wieder bezahlen vermerken und
herr scholz 20 jahre sollen die menschen
die kredite ab stocke dass ihr plan aber
nur in fünf jahre von 2013 bis 2018 sind
die vermögen der reichsten haushalte in
deutschland fast um die hälfte gewachsen
sie bitten wieder die normalbürger zur
kasse und schonen die fetten konnten und
das ist inakzeptabel meine damen und
herren wir
haben gegen vorschlag gemacht wir haben
gegen vorschlag gemacht das steht sogar
im grundgesetz artikel 106 eine
einmalige vermögensabgabe und der konrad
adenauer genauso angewendet worden war
übrigens kein linker und das diw keine
vorfeldorganisation der linken hat das
geprüft praktikabel sagen die unser
vorschlag trifft nur 0,7 prozent der
bevölkerung nur die allerreichsten im
land das sind diejenigen die union und
fdp immer sagt spenden die sollen
betroffen werden und ich sage es ist
feige falls sie sich nicht mit den
superreichen anlegen und es ist unsozial
weil sie die schuldenlast das land
weiter spalten wird meine damen und
herren was muss ich das man muss ich das
machen nicht vorstellen
die krankenpflegerin die die korona
patienten rettet bezahlt mit ihrem
steuergeld die staatshilfen die an bmw
bezahlt werden und bmw schüttet dieses
geld in form von dividenden aus oder
andere mann eine frau klappen deren
vermögen täglich täglich um drei
millionen täglich um drei millionen
steigt warum fordern diese idee warum
fordern sie dieses geld nicht zurück
staatshilfen kassieren und dividenden
ausschütten dass es inakzeptabel
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das alte
leistungs und wohlstands versprechen des
landes meinen kindern wird es einmal
besser gehen das geht wenn überhaupt
wird das nur noch eingeschränkt und das
ein sehr schlechter befund für unser
land für unser land und auch ein
ergebnis von 16 jahren angela merkel für
ein deutschland wie wir gut und gerne
leben haben sie vor der letzten wahl
versprochen haben sie das geschafft und
wenn ja für wen auch da eine zahl jedem
dritten arbeitnehmer und jeder dritten
arbeitnehmerin in vollzeit wohlgemerkt
brot nach 45 jahren eine rente von unter
1100 euro netto das ist ein armutsrisiko
und das ist nicht hinnehmbar meine damen
und herren deutschland ein hochlohnland
für viele menschen ist das ein märchen
deutschland hat ein gewaltiges
lohnproblem und das belastet im übrigen
auch die sozialkassen er schaut sie
haben über die altenpflegerin geräten
ich will sie mal darauf aufmerksam
machen 17.000 altenpflegerinnen und
altenpfleger in unserem land müssen zum
sozialamt und aufstocken weil sie von
ihrem lohn nicht leben können das ist
doch beschämend meine damen und herren
das ist die wahrheit klassen und nicht
handeln
die helden des alltags ist sie an der
kasse teilweise ihr leben riskiert haben
oder ihre gesundheit zumindest haben
weniger in der tasche und gleichzeitig
scheffeln die eigentümer der ketten
milliarden das doch obszön und dann
haben sie was zu den renten gesagt herr
scholz die renten stabil die retten
seien stabil und wir wollen sie stabil
halten was denken sie eigentlich fast
schon rentner der 45 jahre gearbeitet
hat und 2650 euro bekommen hat ist der
durchschnittsverdienst was denken sie
was der so kriegt nach 45 jahren ich
kann es ihnen sagen
1100 euro netto das ist nicht stabil und
wenn überhaupt ist es sehr niedrig
stabil 45 jahre nahezu
durchschnittsverdiener und dann soziale
abstieg im alter das ist die realität in
den gut und gerne deutschland frau
merkel und die sozialdemokraten die bei
olaf scholz seit 1998
habt ihr 19 jahre regiert und davon
haben wir 19 jahre die zuständigkeit für
rente gehabt und diese 19 jahren war für
die rentner stabil schlecht und das muss
sich ändern wir brauchen eine große
rentenreform
es ist doch nicht erklärbar es ist doch
nicht erklärbar dass ein rentner
im schnitt 800 euro weniger rente
bekommt als ein rentner in salzburg und
da gibt es gründe für dann gibt es
gründe für beim gleichen verdienst die
arbeitnehmer in deutschland der
stärksten wirtschaft europas werden mit
unterdurchschnittlichen renten
abgespeist das ist nicht akzeptieren
damit muss schluss sein die löhne und
die renten müssen steigen leistung muss
ich für die wahren leistungsträger
wieder lohnen meine damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
im jahr 2009 10 haben 40 personen
jeweils mehr als 100 millionen geerbt
oder geschenkt bekommen und davon haben
immerhin 31 0 steuernde 20 sie haben
über 100 millionen geerbt haben null
steuern bezahlt aber bei der
arbeitsleistung der bürger da greifen
sie voll zu das hat überhaupt nichts mit
leistungsgerecht ich zu tun
wir brauchen entlastung bei den
geringverdienern und bei der mittels
allerhöchste zeit für große steuerreform
nach unseren vorschlägen hätte die
krankenschwester der busfahrer 100 euro
mehr im monat oder familien mit kleinen
und geringen mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen hätten 500 euro im monat mehr
das hat das diw rechnet ich finde das
ist dringend notwendig und weil die
energiekosten alle damen und herren
seine glanzleistung am ende ihrer
regierung die mieterinnen und mieter
tragen allein die mehrkosten für den co2
preis bei heizung und warmwasser kalt
duschen sollen die mieter das empfehlen
die immobilien lobby und leute aus ihrer
fraktion frau merkel die verschwundene
bisschen früh
ich finde das ist eine unverschämtheit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen noch ein
wort zur klimapolitik die
bundeskanzlerin hat gesagt klimawandel
funktioniert nur wenn die menschen
mitgenommen werden was ist denn die
realität familien zahlen in diesem jahr
600 euro mehr für energie aber ihr
versprechen wahr doch mit der
klimapolitik die bürgerinnen und bürger
zu entlassen wo ist denn die entlastung
den strompreis wollten sie senken aber
in deutschland wird um 1 30 prozent
höherer strompreis als sonst in europa
gezahlt was ist denn das für eine
politik von der alten maya gute
besserung im übrigen ich habe den
verkehrsminister gefragt was denn von
der co2 bepreisung im januar wieder die
musik missions- senkung ist 2025 2,5
prozent donnerwetter sie verbessern die
situation in fünf jahren um 2,5 prozent
und dafür ziehen sie den leuten beim
tanken beim heizen das geld aus der
tasche ihre klimapolitik ist ineffizient
und sie ist teuer meine damen und herren
der verkehrsminister hat mal raus
geantwortet
fernverkehr
pendlerverkehr wird nicht zeit war
schrittweise von der straße auf die
schiene verlegt nein man könnte es ja
annehmen wenn man die pariser klimaziele
erreichen will nein es gibt genau in die
andere richtung neue rekorde auf der
straße und rückgang auf der schiene
promis runter von der straße und einen
masterplan für den güterverkehr das wäre
die richtige maßnahme für das thema
meine damen und herren aber es geht
natürlich nicht das geht natürlich nicht
wenn die csu das verkehrsministerium
klett zwölf jahren führt bahnkunden
autofahrer und radfahrer haben was
besseres verdient als die csu meine
damen und herren
will eine bemerkung zum thema
afghanistan sagen weil es hier noch mal
eine große rolle spielt und ich will
daran erinnern gerhard schröder und
joschka fischer haben deutschland in
diesem krieg geführt und der einsatz ist
der schwärzeste punkt in ihre
außenpolitische bilanz vor merkel keines
der ziele was in den mandats
begründungen und ich kann ihnen nur
empfehlen die alle noch mal zu lesen
keines dieser ziele wurde erreicht meine
damen und herren und ich will in dieser
an dieser stelle war sehr sehr deutlich
sagen nicht die partei die 20 jahre
gegen den krieg und die im übrigen für
die frühzeitige evakuierung sich hier im
bunde
gemeinsam mit grünen und sogar mit der
fdp nicht die ist verantwortungslos
sondern andere haben außenpolitisch und
sicherheitspolitisch verantwortungslos
agiert diejenigen die 20 jahre das leben
von soldaten gefährdet haben die zu
toten geführt haben die sind
verantwortlich und dass er grosse brömer
sagt werden die rettungsflüge abgelegt
das einfach mal völlig falsch wir haben
das hier beantragt sie haben es
abgelehnt und dann haben sie hier ein
schluss mandat vorgelegt den man nicht
zustimmen konnte wir wollten so viel wie
möglich evakuieren das wollen wir im
übrigen noch heute ihre bilanz ist doch
vorher 138 ortskräfte und da tun sie
sich noch dicke das gegenteil ist der
fall
verantwortungsvolle politik läuft anders
und wenn es ein ergebnis gibt da muss
man darüber 1 ganz klar sagen
interventionen und beteiligungen
eskalation das ist nun wirklich
dramatisch gescheitert und da auch eine
erinnerung an ihre legislatur in diesen
vier jahren haben sie für
22,5 milliarden
rüstungsexporte genehmigt sie
exportieren den tod und die konzerne
verdient blutige profite mit diesem geld
das ist inakzeptabel rüstungsexporte
auch nach afghanistan nach pakistan
das geht nun nicht meine damen und
herren ich
sage ihnen ganz klar wir wollen nicht
dass deutschland von den nazis auch
schon gegangen wenn ich rede gehen hier
alles was das für ein zeichen wird ist
deutschland von der laschet von herrn
merz herrn steuer oder auch von herrn
linda den weg zurück in die neoliberale
mottenkiste g wir machen eine politik
für millionen und nicht für millionäre
millionen im land würden profitieren von
einem mindestlohn von zwölf oder 13 euro
millionen würden mit unserem
steuerkonzept krankenschwestern paket
wurden deutlich entlastet meine damen
und herren und endlich würden wir eine
kindergrundsicherung durchsetzen können
damit kinderarmut ernsthaft bekämpft
wird gemeinsam mit grünen und
sozialdemokraten und millionen
rentnerinnen und rentner müssten nicht
mehr um ihr auskommen banken meine damen
und herren weil alle einzahlen müssen
auch sie hier alle müssen in die
rentenkasse einzahlen
am 26 september geht es um eine
richtungsentscheidung und ich sage ganz
klar die staatspolitisch verwahrloste
union masten dieses aserbaidschan affäre
fc eigene tasche wiederhole ich hier
gerne die müssen raus aus der regierung
die bürgerinnen und bürger wollen keine
und jungs regierung mehr und wollen auch
nicht dass seine fdp in die regierung
kommt hier haben fünften märz noch
herren köpfe in thüringen mit gewählt
hat die frage ist ganz einfach linke
oder lindner ist die frage ob spd und
grüne real ihr wahlprogramm umsetzen
wollen ich will zum schluss gerne dem
satz von christian lindner abgewandelt
wiederholen es ist besser gut mit der
linken zu regieren als falsch mit linda
zu regieren unser land brauche ein
politikwechsel eine soziale regierung
das ist unser angebot an die bürgerinnen
und bürger herzlichen dank
das war der spitzenkandidat und
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken dietmar
bartsch er fordert einen
regierungswechsel mit beteiligung der
linken eine einmalige vermögensabgabe
gerechtere löhne und renten mehr rechte
für kinder umstritten bleibt jedoch die
außenpolitik ein thema an dem eine
zusammenarbeit mit spd und grünen
scheitern könnte nächste rednerin ist
die kanzlerkandidatin der grünen
annalena baerbock
[Applaus]
herr präsident sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen die über zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer es ist ja verlockend im
wahlkampf jetzt drei wochen vor der
bundestagswahl zu versprechen keine
sorge es wird alles so bleiben wie
bisher
aber die menschen in unserem land wissen
doch dass wir nur das erhalten können
was uns lieb und teuer ist wenn wir
endlich veränderung angehen wenn wir uns
endlich den großen herausforderungen
unserer zeit aktiv stellen und nicht
weiter abwarten diese bundestagswahl
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben das sehr
treffend gesagt ist eine richtungswahl
diese bundestagswahl ist eine
richtungswahl weil sich entscheidet ob
die nächste bundesregierung noch aktiv
einfluss auf die klimakrise nehmen kann
oder nicht und deswegen muss die frage
klimaschutz im mittelpunkt der nächsten
bundesregierung stehen
und ich finde das nicht nur befremdlich
sondern ich finde das wirklich auch mit
blick auf all die menschen in unserem
land die gerade alles tun um im aartal
und an anderen orten wiederaufbau zu
leisten da sind friseure da sind
handwerker die unter der woche arbeiten
und dann am wochenende am wochenende
kommen und freiwillig helfen häuser
wieder aufzubauen
finde ich es wirklich unverantwortlich
dass hier in dieser debatte zur lage
deutschlands in dieser situation wir
darüber sprechen dass zu recht das
unterstützen wir aus vollem herzen 30
milliarden euro für den wiederaufbau
bereitgestellt werden aber diese 30
milliarden euro werden doch nichts daran
ändern dass wir in zukunft bessere
vorsorge treffen wenn solche
extremwetterereignisse wiederkommen sie
werden nichts daran ändern dass wir
klimaschutzmaßnahmen betreiben oder
nicht wenn wir ernst meinen dass dieser
moment einen moment war über den wir
nicht hinweggehen können beim menschen
alles verloren haben dann muss
klimaschutz im mittelpunkt der nächsten
bundesregierung stehen als klima geben
weil wir eine verantwortung haben als
politik eine verantwortung dafür haben
menschen zu schützen ich war wie sie
letzte woche wieder vor ort und da
stehen einem bundespolizisten gegenüber
und beschreiben noch einmal die
situation dass helferinnen und helfer
eigentlich vor ort waren aber dann der
digitalfunk der digitalfunk im jahr
2021 nicht funktioniert hat wir haben
erschreckende berichte darüber gehört
dass feuerwehrleute gesagt haben wir
hätten drei tage früher kommen können
wir hätten hubschrauber schicken können
aber es hat nicht funktioniert weil es
keine gemeinsame zusammenarbeit im
katastrophenschutz mit der bundes gegen
de gibt und sie stehen hier und sitzen
hier
einige wochen danach und dieses ganze
thema wie wappnen wir uns zukünftig
gegen diese katastrophen spielt hier
absolut keine rolle da schützt unsere
sicherheit in zukunft nicht wir brauchen
endlich eine klimapolitik die auch
vorsorge und schutz aufgebaut ist und
das bedeutet auch ein bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz passiert
verantwortung übernimmt weil ja
verantwortungsvolle politik bedeutet
dass man aufgrund eines solchen tages
seine politik ändert wenn man sie dass
seine politik in die sackgasse wissen
was denn sonst was denn sonst sollen wir
tun wenn wir erleben das extremwetter
ereignisse zu nehmen was denn sonst
sollen wir tun wenn die erleben deshalb
südeuropa abbremst das jetzt in new york
wasserfluten in u bahn schächte herr
einstürzen das ist doch der punkt wo man
handeln muss und wo man sich sagt wir
machen einfach weiter wie bisher und
dann schauen wir mal das ist das größte
risiko unserer zeit und deswegen die
zentrale aufgabe für unsere generation
und ja wir sind im wahlkampf ja wir sind
in einem wahlkampf herr scholz und herr
laschet aber wahlkampf heißt doch nicht
über die sorgen der menschen einfach
hinwegzugehen junge menschen und zwar
nicht nur freies for future die auf die
straße gehen sondern man hört dass von
psychologinnen und psychologen man hört
dass von erzieherinnen und erzieher dass
kinder sich sorgen machen darüber wie
werde ich eigentlich in zukunft in
diesem land leben was passiert
eigentlich was passiert eigentlich wenn
meine kita gerade weggespült wurde diese
frage hören erzieherinnen und erzieher
jetzt in nordrhein westfalen und in
rheinland pfalz und da können sie doch
einfach nicht sagen auf die ängste
dieser kinder versteht doch bitte unsere
angst über eine benzinpreis debatte ist
noch viel größer nein wir sind die
erwachsenen wir sind die politikerinnen
und politiker die sagen wir werden alles
dafür tun
ängste zu nehmen all diese ängste sind
real ein kind was 2018 geboren ist die
erlebt nicht einmal in ihrem leben ein
jahrhundert hochwasser sondern nach all
den prognosen die wir derzeit haben
werden diese hochwasser alle zehn jahre
kommt diese sturzfluten alle paar jahre
kommen und deswegen ist es jetzt zeit
dass politisch zu verändern und sie
sagen ganz von der fdp und von der cdu
das soll mal der markt regeln vielleicht
haben sie heute die zeitung
aufgeschlagen in der sz wurde das noch
mal berechnet wenn das allein der markt
regeln soll dann kostet die tonne co2
2800 euro
das ist zutiefst sozial ungerecht und
die klimakrise die regel kein markt weil
dem markt sind menschen herzlich egal
es braucht eine politik es braucht eine
politik die sagt wir machen das jetzt es
braucht eine politik wie sagt wir machen
das jetzt anstatt 17 jahre weiter in der
kohle drinzubleiben 17 jahre weiter und
entscheid unterscheiden sie sich
zwischen 10 und spd an keiner stelle und
der stolz sie reden ja oft von respekt
aber wie respektvoll ist es in die
lausitz zu fahren und sagen ich werde
weiter für den kohleausstieg
2038 eintreten und ein paar tage später
dann bei den umweltverbänden zu sagen
2034 wäre eigentlich auch ganz in
ordnung das ist für mich kein respekt
sondern das zeugt davon dass es keinen
kurs gehen der klimapolitik gibt bei der
spd und bei ihnen wenn sie dieses land
anführen wollen
17 jahre weiter und sie haben ja sie
haben wir ein klimaschutzgesetz
beschlossen wo richtigerweise drinsteht
wenn ein sektor das nicht erreicht da
muss man schauen wie das in einem
anderen sektor geregelt wird wenn sie 17
jahre lang weiter co2 aus kohle
verstromung wollen dann bedeutet das
dass das so viel co2 ist für alle
gebäude zusammen dann erklären sie mir
an den mieterinnen und mieter dass die
jetzt die ganzen klima aufgaben
übernehmen wollen weil sie nicht den mut
haben den kohleausstieg auf 2.030
endlich vorzuziehen
und das dramatische an der situation
deswegen dass jetzt kein fehler schnitts
werden wird wie wir diese klammen
klimaneutralität es erreichen können ist
dass sie acht jahre als große koalition
dieses land regiert haben in einer zeit
der vollbeschäftigung der guten und
sprudelnden steuereinnahmen niedrigster
zinsen und einfach diese chance nicht
genutzt haben sie haben es vermasselt
auf gut deutsch den weg zur
klimaneutralität endlich einzusteigen
und das ist schön dass sie sagen wir
reden jetzt auch seitdem der wahlkampf
begonnen hat mit stahlkonzern und
chemiekonzern die das eigentlich sehen
wissen sie die deutsche industrie ist
schon seit ein paar jahren deutlich
weiter als diese bundesregierung
der bdi hat auf seiner jahrestagung
deutlich gemacht die fehlende
planungssicherheit weil es keine
richtungsentscheidung von der großen
koalition gegeben haben ist eines unser
größten probleme für den
zukunftsstandort deutschland und ich
zitiere hier mal hier angus wurm es
reicht nicht klimaneutralität per gesetz
vorzuschreiben die politik muss auch
dringend etwas dafür tun dass dieses
ziel auch erreicht werden kann und
politische entscheidungen treffen und
genau darum geht es jetzt nicht
klimaschutz auf der karte zu schreiben
sondern politische entscheidungen zu
treffen und das heißt zwei prozent der
landesfläche gefällt kraft nutzen das
bedeutet den kohleausstieg vorzuziehen
und ab 2030 nur noch die missions- freie
autos zuzulassen und es bedeutet auch
eine solarpflicht auf jedes dach und
dass sie selbst diesen antrag hier im
deutschen bundestag nicht zugelassen
haben bzw der geschäftsordnung
weggewischt haben zeigt wenn die große
koalition wenn sie herr scholz oder sie
herr laschet demnächst hier weiter
regieren wollen dann wird das mit den
klimaschutzzielen einfach nichts werde
und jetzt in einer situation wo die wo
die finanzielle situation eben nicht
mehr so gut dasteht wie in den letzten
jahren müssen wir klare prioritäten
setzen weil die frau bundeskanzlerin
haben von den gleichwertigen
lebensverhältnissen gesprochen ja das
steht in unserem grundgesetz dass es
eine der zentralen aufgaben aber wenn
wir mal genauer hinschauen in unserem
land dann erleben wir ein riesengroßes
problem das wir neben nicht nur in
ländlichen regionen kein internet haben
sondern in ganz ganz vielen bereichen
unseres landes bei der digitalisierung
dem zukunftsthema nicht erst seit heute
sondern in den letzten zehn jahren sind
wir bei den 20 größten industrienationen
auf dem drittletzten platz das ist ihre
regierungsbilanz von acht jahren großer
koalition in der digitalisierung im
schienenbereich es ist so dass
mittlerweile jede sechste weiche jede
sechste brücke und jedes sechste gleich
reparaturbedürftig sind und jetzt
sprechen sie über modernisierung die
modernisierung hätten sie in den letzten
acht jahren angehen müssen
und wenn wir diese zweite also nicht
einfach hinnehmen wollen dann müssen sie
sich jetzt klar entscheiden und
priorisieren sorgen wir jetzt für
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse
investieren wir jetzt in unsere
infrastruktur oder nehmen wir weiterhin
dass wir ein investitionsstau von 140
milliarden euro in unserem land haben
und ich will das nicht ich möchte dass
man auch im ländlichen raum mobil
unterwegs ist ich möchte dass wir auch
an allen orten in unserem land
vernünftige schulen und einen internet
haben und deswegen braucht die
schuldenbremse eine erweiterung durch
eine investitions regel und dass sie
sich der weiteren erreichen minister
gegenstelle zeigt dass der respekt vor
der zukunft offensichtlich nicht so groß
ist all diejenigen die wirklich mal
unterwegs sind im leben die ihr leben
doch was das bedeutet wenn wir nicht in
unsere daseinsvorsorge investieren
grundschülerinnen und grundschüler der
dritten vierten klassen noch nicht
schwimmen können weil die schwimmbäder
im ländlichen raum zu machen
ebenso kunst und kultur alle haben
gesagt ja irgendwie dieses
systemrelevant aber genau da wird jetzt
gespart werden wenn wir eben die
investitionen nicht bereitstellen und
das sehen so einer situation als union
jetzt sagen unsere steuervorschläge sind
vor allen dingen die reichsten zehn
prozent zu entlasten anstatt in die
daseinsvorsorge und den zusammenhalt in
unserer gesellschaft investieren zeigt
auch in welche richtung sie sich in
zukunft entscheiden
und der hälfte
da hilft es aber wählt das ihn jetzt
herr scholz einfällt dass wir eine
kindergrundsicherung brauchen wir haben
das hier im deutschen bundestag immer
wieder in all den jahren diskutiert und
es war ihrem ministerium im
familienausschuss was immer wieder
deutlich gesagt hat auch nie
kindergelderhöhung darüber reden wir mal
aber die frage von anhebung der
hartz-iv-regelsätze das gehen wir nicht
an jede mutter die weiß wie es am ende
des monats von den hartz4
kinderregelsätzen als familie zu leben
die muss sich an so einem schönen
sommertag immer wieder überlegen eis ist
nicht drin schwimmbad ist nicht drin die
neuen fußballschuhe sind wir auch nicht
drin weil das was ihre kinder und
familienpolitik bisher war für jedes
kämpfte kind in diesem land bedeutet
dass man 1 euro 50 zur verfügung hat als
mutter für sein kind und das reicht
vorne und hinten nicht aus
und weil wir gerade bei steuern und
gerechtigkeit sind sehr ausgerechnet den
kampf gegen steuerbetrug lieber weiter
mit fax und brief führen will denn frage
ich wirklich ernsthaft welcher
gesellschaft wollen sie eigentlich
dienen und dass sie sich dass sie sich
aus angst vor einer fetten dicke
schlagzeile in einer großen zeitung
genau in diesem moment auch als
finanzminister weggucken zeigt
offensichtlich dass sie aus warburg und
wirecard nicht wirklich etwas gelernt
haben
der amtseid den amtseid in einige von
tieren schon ein paar mal hier
geschworen haben aber vielleicht in
seiner bedeutung mittlerweile vergessen
haben der amtseid heißt kraft dem wohle
des deutschen volkes widmen und schaden
von ihm zuwenden und schaden von ihm
zuwenden bedeutet vorzusorgen eine
vorausschauende politik zu machen im
klimaschutz bei der frage gerechtigkeit
und vor allen dingen auch mit blick auf
den kampf gegen die pandemie
wir stehen gerade wieder vor einem
corona herbst wir sehen dass die
infizierten zahlen massiv nach oben
steigen und die hospitalisierung quote
wir haben krankenschwestern pflegern und
ärzten gesagt das wird nicht noch einmal
passiert dass wir hier klatschen und ihr
tag und nacht durcharbeiten müssen und
was passiert jetzt es müsste jetzt
einige entscheidung getroffen werden von
dieser bundesregierung von cdu und spd
zu sagen wir rauschen nicht nur mal in
synchroner herz sein und da bringt es
nichts zu sagen ich verspreche die
schulen bleiben offen und ich verspreche
es wird keinen weiteren locker und geben
sondern ihre aufgabe ist jetzt dafür zu
sorgen dass das auch kommt und das heißt
in einem solchen moment den mut zu haben
dass es an hotspots natürlich auch eine
zweig regelung geben muss damit die
schulen in zukunft auch wirklich offen
bleiben und kinder nicht in die acht
serien raum es heißt jetzt einmal wieder
einfach nichts getan
und den schülerinnen und schüler zweimal
die woche getestet werden warum soll das
nicht auch am arbeitsplatz möglich sein
diese debatte hatten wir schon mal in
diesem hohen haus und nach anderthalb
jahren ist es an der zeit dass das
endlich umgesetzt wird
und dann haben sie eigentlich
gesagt sie wollten jetzt in drei stunden
über afghanistan und eine
verantwortungsvolle außenpolitik
diskutieren das war ihr argument von cdu
und spd warum sind sie dem top per
geschäftsordnung afghanistan hier nicht
zugelassen haben und dann ist es doch
ein ganz schön hohe stück das sie sich
danke hinstellen auch sie herr scholz
und nichts zu diesem thema sagen nichts
dazu sagen was in den letzten wochen
eigentlich in der bundesregierung ist
und seit der seit der letzten ab gar
nicht eingebaut sind ja noch neue dinge
an das licht der öffentlichkeit gekommen
dass sie die listen von denen wir hier
vor wochen gesprochen haben gar nicht
weitergegeben haben dass menschen vor
dem flughafen standen angerufen worden
sind und dann standen sie aber nicht auf
der liste drauf um durchzukommen
stattdessen wurden diese listen mit
namen von menschen die in lebensgefahr
schweben irgendwie an die taliban
gegeben und dass sie darüber hier und
heute nicht reden wollen das ist einfach
unverantwortlich
und es geht
es geht dabei nicht nur um die
zukünftige außenpolitik der
bundesrepublik deutschland es geht auch
um die frage welche art von politik
wollen wir eigentlich machen eine
politik wo sich eine regierung in
schwierigen momenten einfach weg durch
eine politik wo sich eine große
koalition hinstellt und sagt mit dem
parlament möchten wir darüber jetzt
nicht diskutieren
das ist nicht nur eine unverantwortliche
außenpolitik sondern das zeigt auch dass
man kein respekt vor diesem hohen haus
hier hat und dass die
verteidigungsministerien jetzt alleine
einlösungs antrag in ihrem haus durch
setzt sie aber nicht bereit sind das
hier im deutschen bundestag zu
beschließen das ist wirklich ein unding
und ja sie können das per
geschäftsordnung der tagesordnung holen
aber sie können ihre verantwortung beim
afghanistan debakel nicht einfach
wegwischen in der nächsten legislatur
wird es ein untersuchungsausschuss dazu
geben und
zwar nicht nur mit fehler aufzuarbeiten
sondern weil deutschland endlich wieder
eine aktive deutsche außenpolitik
braucht dieses wegducken in der
afghanistan politik ist doch ein spiegel
dessen was passiert ist in den letzten
acht jahren in europa deutschland ist
das stärkste land in der europäischen
union deutschland ist das land was immer
wieder sagt wir wollen europa eigentlich
weiterbauen auf ihrem eigenen
koalitionsvertrag
das haben sie irgendwie vergessen
offensichtlich in den letzten vier
jahren stand als ovag titel drauf ein
neuer aufbruch für europa und was ist
dann passiert
als hermagor gesagt hat wir müssen jetzt
mal den globalen kampf gegen
steuerbetrug wirklich angehen mit blick
auf eine digital steuer am siegel sagt
er stolz lassen wir das lieber mal sein
geld sind sie nach getrödelt mit
reichlich verspätung und die franzosen
haben das erst mal alleine gemacht als
die eu kommissionspräsident in von der
union gesagt hat europa soll der erste
klimaneutrale kontinent sein fällt ihnen
nichts besseres ein weiter in brüssel
dafür zu lobbyieren das aber mit blick
auf die auto grenzwerte bitte mal nicht
so schnell gemacht wird und jetzt macht
das halt daimler alleine die stillen
habe 2025 nur noch die autos her und das
und das und das heftigste das heftigste
ist passiert und ich komme zum schluss
herr präsidentin der europäischen
flüchtlingspolitik
humanität und ordnung sind die pfeiler
unserer gemeinsam werte union und was
haben sie vier jahre lang gemacht sich
unter viktor orban versteckt und gesagt
so lange der sich nicht bewegt bewegen
wir uns auch nicht europa wurde immer
gebaut dass einige sich zusammengetan
haben beim euro bei schengen bei der ost
erweiterung und genau dieser moment den
brauchen wir jetzt wieder in deutschland
was europapolitisch führt und sich nicht
hinter viktor orban versteckt
spiele von ihrem boss angekündigten
aufruf für europa ist nichts übrig
geblieben außer einer reise meiner
beiden mitbewerber diese woche nach
paris um das letzte noch zu retten so
gestalten wir nicht nur ein aufbruch in
europa sondern so wird es auch mit dem
klimaschutz nicht und deswegen brauchen
wir eine regierung die verantwortung
übernehmen den mut für neues werk für
einen klimagerechten wohlstand in
deutschland und eine zukunft der
gemeinde
das war die wohl eine kanzlerkandidatin
annalena baerbock die eine klima
regierung forderten folgen der flut die
folgen von extrem wettern müsse hier im
bundestag diskutiert werden das sei aber
heute kein thema so ihre kritik ebenso
wenig werde das debakel des afghanistan
einsatzes sowie die künftige
außenpolitik diskutiert es folgt nun der
kanzlerkandidat der union armin laschet
er ist nicht mitglied des bundestages
aber als mitglied des bundesrates dafür
hier jederzeit reden
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
bundeskanzlerin hat heute diese debatte
eröffnet und sie hat einen vergleich
gezogen
vom jahr 2005 zum jahr 2021
das sieht ja das verstehe ich dass sie
da euro je sagen weil 2005 rot grün
regiert hat die bilanz waren fünf
millionen arbeitslose wir hatten ein
geringeres
bruttoinlandsprodukt und deshalb ist es
gut einmal daran zu erinnern dass das 16
gute jahre für deutschland waren die wir
hier erlebt haben
wenn jetzt mitten in der pandemie
2,6 millionen menschen ohne arbeit sind
und da mal 5 millionen dann heißt das es
gibt auch weniger armut armut bei
kindern hängt auch davon ab ob eltern
arbeitsmöglichkeiten haben und deshalb
ist das das erste wir müssen für mehr
arbeitsplätze sorgen das zweite sieht
malen hier bilder
über
umwelt- und klimapolitik vor 16 jahren
kam knapp 16 prozent des stroms aus
erneuerbaren energien heute sind es 46
es ist viel bewegt worden in diesen
jahren und deshalb ist es richtig
dass wir an dieser stelle auch der
bundeskanzlerin danken sie hat dieses
land gut durch viele krisen geführt und
all ihre schwarz malerei hat wenig mit
dem zu tun was in diesen 16 jahren
leistet worden ist
und dann gibt es immer diesen netten
spruch ja warum wollt ihr jetzt was
neues machen er hat das 16 jahre zeit
was ist er bei der digitalisierung
passiert christian lindner hat das auch
so ein wenig an intoniert ja die welt ja
die wahrheit die wahrheit wenn sie
wahrheit rufen da bin ich immer
skeptisch
2005 hat netflix per post dvds
verschickt die welt hat sich seither ein
wenig verändert und jetzt so zu tun so
zu tun als wenn man im jahre 2021 so
reagieren müssten wir mal 2005 reagiert
hätte ist einfach unseriös wir haben in
dieser pandemie alle gemerkt dass bund
länder und kommunen auf die
herausforderungen unserer zeit nicht
richtig eingestellt sind wenn die
gesundheitsämter mit faxen arbeiten ist
das eine ist das ist dass eine kommunale
aufgabe wenn die länder nicht schnell
gesuch sind bei der bildung frau berbalk
ist es eine länder aufgabe aber immer so
zu tun als sei alles diese
bundesregierung schuld in elf ländern
regieren sie mit und wenn es da nicht
gut läuft sind sie auch dafür
verantwortlich man kann sich nicht immer
aus der verantwortung herausziehen
und deshalb ist nach 16 jahren
vieles jetzt neu zu gestalten wir stehen
an einer epochenwende wir spüren dass
alle europa ist unter druck gekommen
europa hat in der pandemie gemerkt wie
abhängig man von einer fremden macht war
selbst bei simpelsten medizinischen
gütern und insofern
wird unsere
europäische welt jetzt auf einem werte
basierten gesellschafts und
wirtschaftsmodell diese gestaltung der
zukunft auf sich nehmen müssen das geht
nur europäisch und deshalb brauchen wir
einen zusammenschluss europas und für
unser menschenbild einzutreten gegenüber
china einem herausforderer
gleichzeitig system rivale und partner
gegenüber anderen in der welt und das
ist eine der großen aufgaben die wir
jetzt anpacken müssen das gleiche gilt
für den klimawandel wir können hier
kleinteilige maßnahmen diskutieren wir
werden auch als deutschland unseren teil
leisten müssen aber wir werden diese
große aufgabe nur bewältigen als globale
aufgabe als klima außenpolitik und da
werden wir auch mit ländern reden müssen
die unser menschenbild nicht teilen mit
russland mit china mit der arabischen
welt nur wenn wir hier zu mehr
gemeinsamkeiten kommen werden wir diese
menschheitsaufgabe lösen und deshalb
rate ich uns etwas weg von diesem klein
klein hinzu dieser großen aufgabe die
jetzt in den nächsten zehn jahren vor
und wir müssen will dazu nachher noch
kommen zu der frage der äußeren
sicherheit und zu der frage der inneren
sicherheit wir müssen im land mit all
unseren prozessen schneller werden das
hat hier
ja
finanzminister
eben beschrieben ja wir müssten mehr
wohnungen bauen ja stimmt wir müssten
mehr wohnungen bauen sie haben die zeit
aus von helmut kohl gewürdigt wo mehr
wohnungen gebaut worden sind aber sehr
verehrter herr scholz glauben sie denn
allen ernstes
man kriegt mit mehr vorschriften mehr
blockaden mehr regeln
rot-rot-grüner berliner
wohnungsbaupolitik wo zum ersten mal
seit 2009 weniger wohnungen gebaut
worden sind mit dieser methode würden
sie mehr wohnungen in deutschland bauen
ist doch eine absurde vorstellung
die bauvorschriften damals waren ganz
andere jedes jahr werden neue dinge
drauf gelegt in ihren wahlprogrammen
eine menge neuer vorschriften die jetzt
alle kommen sollen sie müssen aber
jemanden der geld investiert ermutigen
dass er das in wohnungen steckt dass es
attraktiv es zu bauen und
bei aller liebe bei aller liebe sehr
verehrter herr scholz man kann nicht mit
der raute durch die gegend laufen und
reden wie saskia esken das passt einfach
nicht zusammen
das gleiche
das gleiche gilt auch für die
wirtschaftspolitik wir haben in der
pandemie mit vielen milliarden und sie
haben das erwähnt
die kurzarbeit bezahlt wir haben
unternehmen hilfe gegeben dass sie gut
durch die krise kommen
das war übrigens möglich weil wir da vor
eine politik gemacht haben die der herr
präsident noch als finanzminister
verantwortet hat die schuldenbremse die
schwarze null
weil man in guten zeiten rücklagen
gebildet hat konnten wir anders als
viele andere europäische länder in der
krise helfen
ihre partei ihr parteivorsitzender
herr walter borjans ich kenne ihn aus
nordrhein westfalen hat gesagt diese
schuldenbremse das ist der fetisch von
wolfgang schäuble
der ist falsch schulden sind gut zur
sollen setzen wie schulden von heute ist
steuerkraft von morgen das war doch die
politik die haben wir gegen sie
durchgesetzt dass wir solide ausweitet
haben und ich fürchte wenn nicht mehr
die union da ist wenn sie nicht mehr an
den kanzler vor sich haben der auf sie
achtet dann werden sie wieder schulden
machen und dann wählen sie wieder
steuern erhöhen wie wir das von ihnen
kennen
deshalb
gehört in den dank an die
bundeskanzlerin natürlich auch gedanken
dass sie in diesen 16 jahren zwölf jahre
gut auf die sozialdemokraten aufgepasst
hat das war eine große leistung
und deshalb muss doch die philosophie
nach der krise sein wir kommen zur
wirtschaftlichen wachstum nur wenn wir
fesseln wegnehmen wenn wir bürokratie
wegnehmen wenn wir freiräume schaffen
damit investiert werden kann und alle
die die jetzt darauf warten wieder zu
investieren dass wir denen nicht das
geld entziehen dass sie für
investitionen brauchen und wir haben
doch vor der pandemie werden doch vor
der pandemie alle diese lehre gemacht
mich wundert dass man das so schnell
vergessen kann
jahrelang ohne neue steuererhöhungen
jedes jahr im frühjahr die
steuerschätzung und am ende des jahres
immer mehr steuereinnahmen weil die
wirtschaft brummte weil die menschen
beschäftigung hatten weil die arbeitslos
niedrig wahrheit war und viele menschen
eingezahlt wieso kann man das so schnell
vergessen warum macht man jetzt wieder
die gleichen fehler die man davor
gemacht hat steuererhöhungen und
schulden machen das ist der falsche weg
und eine bemerkung zu ihnen vor berbalk
sie haben über verlässlichkeit in der
politik gesprochen wir haben dem spd
kanzlerkandidaten vorgeworfen dass er in
der lausitz nach 2038 kohleausstieg und
anderswo andere daten das ist vielleicht
sogar ein berechtigter punkt aber eines
ist unredlich eines ist unredlich und da
haben die grünen am allerwenigsten grund
hier moralisch so überheblich
aufzutreten diese große koalition
diese große koalition
hat als erste eine kohle ausstiegs
kommission berufen und den kohle
ausstieg eingeleitet das ist das erste
was man hier einmal feststellen muss und
diese kommission sollte einen
gesellschaftlichen konsens erzielen aus
gewerkschaften aus arbeitgebern aus
professor schellnhuber vom potsdam
institut aus wissenschaftlern und aus
allen umweltverbänden die daran
beteiligt waren und die sollten prüfen
verfügbarkeit und bezahlbarkeit von
strom und die sind zum enddatum
2038 gekommen sie sind zum enddatum
sie sind zum enddatum 238 gekommen
lassen sie sich mal von michael
vassiliadis oder anderen die letzte
nacht schildern eine einzige gegenstimme
gab es gegen dieses datum das war eine
bürgermeisterin aus dem osten wo seiner
umsiedlung geht alle anderen 27 haben ja
gesagt sie haben dann ein minderheits
votum abgegeben wo sie gesagt haben wir
könnten uns auch 2030 vorstellen aber
bei einem gesellschaftlichen konsens der
wichtig ist in einer solchen frage der
wichtig ist in einer solchen frage haben
sie sich für
2038 entschieden und jetzt wird man
sehen wie sich der co2 preis entwickelt
wie leicht geht es schneller wir in
nordrhein westfalen im westen je
schneller sein aber in ostdeutschland
hat man bereits 1990 brutalste brüche
erleben müssen und dass die menschen mal
das recht darauf haben dass wenn politik
etwas zu sagen dass das mindestens mal
ein jahr haltbar ist und nicht direkt in
frage gestellt wird wenn es gerade hier
umsetzen will das ist der punkt um den
es geht
entstanden hier einen frischen fragen
der kollegen georg
[Applaus]
wyhlen dank herr laschet da sie mich ja
direkt angesprochen haben und da das ja
eine der großen zukunftsfragen für die
nächste bundesregierung sein wird möchte
ich sie als erstes daran erinnern was in
diesem kompromiss drin stand sie haben
ja schon mal was behauptet was nicht der
realität entsprach nämlich dass die
umweltverbände
dass die umweltverbände 1 2 1
2038 schuld sind und deswegen möchte ich
an dieser stelle einmal sagen was in dem
kohlekompromiss drinstand wir haben den
ich hier nämlich in dem deutschen
bundestag beraten und auch das gesetz
was sie dann hier als große koalition
eingebracht haben und das hat bedeutet
dass in dem vorschlag der kohle
kommission drin gestanden hat es gibt
revision punkte wo man immer wieder
überprüfen ob das co2 budget noch
eingehalten wird oder nicht diese
revision punkte haben sie dann hier als
große koalition in dem gesetzentwurf
daraus gestrichen erste fragen wissen
die das eigentlich zweite frage warum
sagen sie dann es wurde eins zu eins
umgesetzt zweiter punkt sie haben anders
als beschlossen datteln 4 als kraftwerk
dass es ans netz geht mit beschlossen
als große koalition das heißt das was
sie hier gesagt haben der
kohlekompromiss wäre eins zu eins hier
eingebracht stimmt einfach nicht und da
jetzt die bundesregierung selber aus dem
bundesumweltministerium
berechnet hat dass wir die klimaziele
verfehlen wäre jetzt doch der punkt zu
sagen das was die kohle kommission
beschlossen hat werden wir die ziele
verfehlen müssen wir den kohleausstieg
vorziehen weil das ein kompromiss an dem
wir uns alle halten daher meine frage an
sie halten sie sich an die zusage wenn
wir die klimaziele verfehlen
zählen wir den kohle ausstieg vor so wie
es gemeinsam beschlossen worden ist
vielen dank für die zwischenfrage frau
bild von frau bär borg die ja auch
kleine erläuterung style noch dabei
hatte der leider nicht stimmte der
leider nicht stimmte ich bedauere dass
die umweltverbände nicht zu dem stehen
was sie damit beschlossen hat
27 jahr stimmen zum endbericht mit dem
datum 28 und 30 da können noch so viele
menschen jetzt im netz versuchen sich
davon zu relativieren ich wünsche mir
verlässlichkeit von denen die so ein
dokument unterschreiben dass der erste
teil meiner antwort der zweite tag
zweiter tag ja es stimmt
es stimmt ja es stimmt es gibt diese
eckpunkte natürlich wird jetzt alle paar
jahre 2023 25 unter nach überprüft ist
das denn umsetzbar haben wir denn den
strom verfügbar wenn man immer neue
ziele festlegt
beschleunigungsphase macht für den
ausbau der erneuerbaren ist ja wichtig
dann muss man aber auch die trassen dazu
bauen dann brauchen wir da planungs und
beschleunigungs verfahren und meistens
ist es ihre fraktion die als erste die
bürgerinitiative gründe gegen die trasse
und die dritte bemerken und das auch
noch mal ein für alle mal klarzustellen
sie haben eben gesagt ein solches
wetterereignis muss man da seine politik
ändern diese wetterereignisse ja datteln
ein schöner das ist jetzt gerade noch
mal gerichtlich überprüfen die
ursprüngliche baugenehmigung ist erteilt
uns von spd und grünen ihre
regierungsrat in nordrhein-westfalen
zutaten tier vielen dank dass sie mich
noch
das ist leider so können sie alles nach
aber jetzt kommt die kernfrage die sie
gerade angesprochen
hier muss man bei einem okay ich werde
es weiter
die die frage die sie gestellter muss
man eigentlich wegen ein das war in
ihrer rede wegen einem solchen wetter
ereignisse die politik ändern
diese wetterereignisse einen uns seit
jahren die jungen leute ältere leute
engagieren sich bei freddie for future
schon länger sind auf den straßen das
thema klima hat klaus töpfer als
umweltminister in oslo 92 bereits auf
die tagesordnung gehoben in der zeit
haben sie sich nicht gegen kohle
engagierte ganze engagement der grünen
in dieser zeit fast 20 jahre ging gegen
die kernkraft das war die falsche
reihenfolge
wenn wir den klimawandel so ernst nehmen
hätten wir erst aus der pole und dann
aus der kernenergie aussteigen müsse das
ist eine frage die man sich sein aber
was ich in den wirklich vorwerfen was
mich ärgert weil es unseriös ist
215 wird das pariser klima protokoll
unterschrieben
jeder weiß das klima ein wichtiges thema
ist und sie beschließen die nordrhein
westfalen gemeinsam mit den
sozialdemokraten wenige monate vor
meinem amtsantritt im jahre 2016 wir
machen braunkohletagebau bis 2045 wir
werden den hambacher forst rodeln und
wir sind es die dann ausgestiegen sind
und sich dann am nächsten tag nach der
wahlniederlage auf die barrikade bei der
anderen seite zu stellen hat mit
seriöser politik nichts zu tun
überhaupt nichts
jetzt komme ich zu einem zweiten punkt
sehr wichtig ist wir müssen wieder zu
wirtschaftlichem wachstum zurückkommen
das geht mit entfesselung mit weniger
bürokratie mit beschleunigten verfahren
mit unterstützung für die familien
unternehmen gerade im ländlichen raum
die jetzt steuererhöhungen als gift für
investitionen empfinden würden aber wir
müssen auch den aufstieg durch bildung
unterstützen christian lindner hat über
diese frage gesprochen die beste
sozialpolitik ist kindern aus hartz 4
herauszuhelfen aufstieg möglich zu
machen unabhängig von der herkunft der
eltern deshalb ist dieser beschluss vom
gestrigen tag im vermittlungsausschuss
ein so wichtiger dass wir auch ganz das
angebot vom 6 bis zum zehnten lebensjahr
jetzt als rechtsanspruch fest schreiben
und deshalb brauchen wir deshalb
brauchen wir hier ein anderes
verständnis von sozialpolitik kinder
stärken kinder stärken ist das richtige
und nicht staatliche umverteilung und
das ist ein fundamentaler unterschied
und das heißt dass wir anerkennen müssen
wir haben in nordrhein westfalen mit der
fdp zusammen talent schulen errichtet im
schwierigsten im schwierigsten stadtteil
die besten schulen bessere ausstattung
bessere bildung bessere lehrer schlüssel
und den kindern auch aus
einwanderfamilien
aufstiegschancen durch bildung
ermöglichen deutsche sprache schon im
kindergarten fördern damit man danach
jede aufstiegschance in dieser
gesellschaft hat und übrigens dass auch
anerkennen das ist der unterschied zu
diesen rechten teil des hauses wir haben
und er wird immer nur zitiert wenn es
gut läuft in uhr sahin beispielsweise
jemanden der hierher kommt kein wort
deutsch spricht vier jahre alt ist dann
gute bildung hat als erstes kind auf das
gymnasium geht sein abitur macht seinen
bildungsweg wach und am ende für die
ganze welt einen impfstoff entwickelt
solche aufstiegsgeschichte solcher
ausschluss geschichten brauchen wir
wieder mehr und ich sage auch dazu diese
vielfalt unserer gesellschaft muss sich
auch in unseren verwaltungen
widerspiegeln muss sich auch in einer
bundesregierung widerspiegeln es gibt
nicht nur so talentierte leute die
impfstoffe entwickeln es gibt viele
viele tausend die immer noch nicht die
chance haben ihre potenziale
einzubringen und auch dafür stehen wir
weil leistungen und bildungsaufstieg
unser prinzip ist und nicht soziale
umverteilung wie sie das in ihrem
programm haben und das dritte thema
das dritte thema ist wie kommen wir denn
so klimaneutralität und das ärgert mich
wenn man da auch immer neue daten in der
zukunft findet was man alles 2045 und
dann und dann machen will zielpunkte
brauchen wir sind wir auch nicht
auseinander
aber was das kunststück doch ist eine
industrie die da ist umzubauen damit die
industriearbeitsplätze auch in zehn und
20 jahren noch da sind dass wir dann
noch stahlindustrie haben dass wir dann
noch automobilindustrie haben mich
wundert dass ja dass selbst bei einer
automobilindustrie die so sich
umgestellt hat wie wir das alle
beschreiben die ganz auf dem weg der
klimaneutralität ist dass es immer noch
gruppen gibt die jetzt gegen die iaa in
münchen demonstrieren sie blockieren
wollen sie stören wollen ich will dass
wir auch in 20 jahren noch
automobilindustrie in deutschland haben
das muss doch wie vorjahres
und ich bin froh dass es diese
ausstellung gibt und dass wir in
deutschland die besten autos bauen und
dann muss man aber auch die grenzwerte
die man festlegt so festlegen dass
jemand damit kommt sie können beim stahl
in brüssel grenzwerte beschließen dann
ist klar das stahlwerk ist dann weder
uns als gitarren duisburg noch im
saarland zu betreiben weil wenn kohle
und eisenerz verbunden wird wird immer
co2 frei sein naturgesetz können sie
auch nicht mit geschäftsordnung
bundestag beschließen dass es nicht mehr
gilt und nicht mit zweidrittelmehrheit
ein naturgesetz ist ein naturgesetz und
wenn man will wenn man will dass die
hier in zukunft noch bleiben muss man
ihnen den weg dahin ermöglichen mit
einem übergang der es möglich macht
grünen stahl zu erzeugen mit mehr
wasserstoff dazu braucht man aber zeit
wenn die morgen abwandern südsee indien
in china irgendwo fahren den stahl dann
10.000 kilometer über die weltmeere mit
hoher co2 belastung und unsere
klimabilanz ist ganz toll weil 6 prozent
weniger stahl produktion drin ist wir
könnten uns wir könnten uns brüsten dass
wir eine tolle klimabilanz haben aber
die industriearbeitsplätze sind weg und
deshalb wundert mich
wundert mich
dass auch die spd so wenig über dieses
thema spricht diese sozial diese
energiewende muss sozialverträglich
gelingen sie muss sozialverträglich
gelingen und diese industrie
arbeitsplätze brauchen wir und deshalb
brauchen wir diesen prozess hin zu einer
klimaneutralen wirtschaft bei der chemie
beim auto weil beim stahl und in vielen
anderen bereichen mehr das geht aber nur
durch forschung das geht durch
innovation das geht nicht dass sie immer
neue auflagen für die industrie machen
denn die sind auf dem wege und wollen es
leisten und ducati es ihnen zehn
beispiele nennen wo das schon sehr
konkret passiert was aber nicht mit
verboten
erreichbar ist und deshalb glaube ich
dass das der kern ist wie macht man das
und dazu braucht man
wirtschaftskompetenz kenntnisse wie ein
unternehmen funktioniert wie ein
strukturwandel geht strukturwandel geht
nicht mit sprüchen sondern
strukturwandel geht nur mit der kenntnis
von prozessen mit innovation mit
investitionen in batterietechnik in
grünen wasserstoff in klimaneutrale
wertstoffe und und und und dazu habe ich
heute von den freundlichen wettbewerbern
keine antworten gehört so wird
deutschland jedenfalls nicht
industrieland bleiben wenn man mit den
konzepten agiert die rot grün heute hier
vorgetragen
wir haben auch wenig geboren
digitalisierung heute gehört das ist der
große schub der jetzt vor uns steht die
verwaltung so umzubauen dass sie
bürgerfreundlicher wird dass das
digitale genutzt wird um diese prozesse
zu erreichen und das dritte wozu wir
überhaupt nichts gehört haben ist die
frage der sicherheit und der sicherheit
in diesem land wenn wir für sozialen
zusammenhalt einstehen wenn wir merken
dass die gesellschaft aggressiver wird
von allen seiten aggression jetzt auch
wieder in der kroner pandemie zu spüren
ist dann heißt das doch dass wir diesen
menschen zuhören müssen dass wir das
dass wir das ernst nehmen müssen was sie
vortragen und dass wir nicht darüber so
leichtfertig hinweg gehen und in der tat
man darf es nicht auch noch befeuern die
millionen menschen die sich getestet
haben lassen und die danach sich haben
impfen lassen sind keine
versuchskaninchen bitte messing sie sich
in ihrer sprache der
bundesfinanzminister weil sie über
dieses thema reden wir haben doch diese
querdenker überall erlebt und ich sage
ihnen auch noch etwas auch aus ihrer
partei wenn da ein querdenker auf die
bühne springt unter herum krakeelt dann
ist es richtig mindestens selbst wenn
man diesen menschen nicht kennt ihn
nicht leicht mit sicherheitskräften weg
bringen zu lassen das befeuert doch die
legende dieser leute die hier sitzen und
die unser land aufhetzen in diesen
fragen deshalb zu hören ernst nehmen was
andere vortragen
und deshalb ist sicherheit ein ganz
wichtiges thema die innere sicherheit
garantiert die
nein vor hendrix es darf niemand leicht
auf die bühne springen aber die frage
ist wenn sie denen dann beruhigen und
dem eine antwort geben ob das nicht die
bessere antwort ist als ihm mit
sicherheitskräften von der bühne zu
beseitigen dass die kernfrage aber
sicherheit ist mehr sicherheit ist mehr
gegen der kampf gegen rechts terrorismus
es ist die größte bedrohung in diesem
land ich weiß nicht ob sie das
bestreiten hatte aber der
rechtsterrorismus ist die größte gefahr
in diesem land weil sie anschläge auf
menschen verübt weil sie anschläge auf
menschen verübt endres buch ns ufa ein
staatsversagen ohne jeden zweifel und
hier brauchen wir klare regeln aber
gleichzeitig haben wir inzwischen einen
fundamentalistischen terrorismus wir
haben
kleinkriminalität die menschen
verunsichert und deshalb muss man das
anpacken und dazu braucht man eine
haltung eine klare haltung wir haben das
landes in nordrhein-westfalen erlebt
anis amri war ein bekannter fall
13 identitäten reiste quer durch das
land jeder wusste wer er ist er war
ständig beobachtet und man hat uns dann
erklärt ja aber festnehmen kann man denn
nicht der ist ja nur ein gefährdung der
hat ja noch nichts gemacht so war die
begründung und man hat auch gesagt
man kann gefährder nicht abschieben denn
es gibt ja keinen straftatbestand jemand
begangen hat und da hat sich etwas
geändert eine grundhaltung dass es
möglich ist wenn jemand gefährder ist
wenn er deutlich macht er will auch
töten und ist bereits zur gewalt dann
kann er festgenommen werden und des
landes verwiesen werden und wir sind 1 1
wir sind ein liberales
weltoffenes land aber wir haben ein
prinzip null toleranz und inzwischen
sind in nordrhein westfalen seit 2017
mit einem paragraphen von dem sie gesagt
haben das geht garnicht
35 gefährder des landes verwiesen worden
wir wollen konsequent sein da mit
sicherheit in diesem land gelingt und
das ist eine frage
die man jetzt gerade nach afghanistan
auch international beantworten muss in
frankreich beginnt morgen der wichtige
prozess gegen die mutmaßlichen
attentäter von paris die anschläge
damals haben frankreich ins herz
getroffen und ich bin morgen dem
französischen präsident sind es
freundlicher weise schon erwähnt worden
und an dem thema können sich jetzt
wieder sehen dass wir mehr europa
brauchen in der terrorismus und
kriminalitätsbekämpfung die attentäter
kamen durch deutschland lebten in
brüssel fuhren nach paris und haben die
anschläge begangen begangen und deshalb
ist es wichtig dass wir hier europäisch
zusammenarbeiten müssen dass wir
frankreich das besonders von
terroranschlägen betroffen war
signalisieren wir gehen diesen weg
zusammen wir werden gemeinsam in europa
für mehr sicherheit sorgen das ist das
versprechen damit terrorismus nicht
wieder so wütend kann wie im jahre 2015
und das zweite
außenpolitisch hat
dieser bundestag einmal beschlossen den
afghanistan-einsatz
2001 nach dem elften september der sich
in wenigen tagen jährt
nicht mit dem argument die taliban zu
beseitigen sondern diesen rechtsfreien
raum der da entstanden ist der ursache
war für weltweiten terrorismus für osama
bin laden für al qaida die aus
afghanistan geplant haben den anschlag
in new york dies zu verhindern das war
das ziel das ist gelungen dieser teil
ist gelungen wir haben mehr hoffnungen
gehabt am ende was sich in afghanistan
verändert das ist leider nicht gelungen
aber die lehre muss sein dass wir jetzt
alles tun die internationale
gemeinschaft und europa das nicht erneut
unter die taliban wieder ein neuer
rechtsfreien raum entsteht der uns hier
in unserer sicherheit bedroht das ist
der eine teil und wir müssen einfach
nach diesem für den für das westliche
bündnis wahrscheinlich größten desaster
seiner gründung erkennen wo müssen wir
besser werden
sind wir europäer wirklich auf alle
ewigkeit nicht in der lage alleine einen
flughafen zu sichern und wenn wir uns
das ziel setzen ja wir müssen auch mal
handeln können wenn die amerikaner nicht
handeln das war einmal der beginn der
europäischen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik
1999 nach den kriegen auf dem balkan
dass wir gesehen haben krieg in europa
völkermord massen vergewaltigungen und
gestoppt hat erst die nato diesen
einsatz weil europa dazu nicht alleine
in der lage waren dann hat man begonnen
eine sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik zu entwickeln die
in fragmenten weitergekommen ist aber 20
jahre später noch nicht so stark ist
dass wir heute auch alleine handeln
könnte und dies muss das ziel sein
hierzu mehr europa zu mehr
handlungsfähigkeit zu kommen das
bedeutet aber auch dass man sich dann
verabredet gemeinsame projekte macht
auch gemeinsame projekte macht zum
schutz unserer soldaten und das dann
aber auch in deutschland das
durchgehalten wird dass wir dann auch
sagen ja wir sind bereit zwei prozent
unserer ausgaben für sicherheit
auszugeben und das werfe ich spd und
grünen vor bei dem ersten teil der
europäischen bekenntnissen sie dabei
aber wenn es dann um die umsetzung geht
wenn es um das gemeinsame
rüstungsprojekt geht wenn es um die
bewaffnete drohnen geht dann liegt die
vorlage seit monaten beim finanzminister
weil er sich nicht gegen seine eigene
partei durchsetzt und das ist das
problem was wir haben
und deshalb muss man der haltung haben
man muss sich ziele setzen und dann
dafür auch die mehrheiten haben und will
zum schluss kommen wir haben eben ein
paar gehört das hörte sich an wie eine
bewerbungsrede die herr barth hier
vorgetragen hat liebe ihr habt auch sie
erfolgreich sind da tun wir jetzt alles
dass das nicht passiert damit dass kein
rot-rot-grünes bündnis gibt aber
sie haben das hier so charmant
vorgetragen um mit ihrer sprache zu
sprechen müssen die leute ist draußen
sagen völker hört die signale
also wir wissen was da geplant ist wir
wissen was hier an begegnungen schon
auch in diesem haus schon vor den
sommerferien statt gefunden hat und
deshalb haben die bürgerinnen und bürger
ein recht darauf ein recht darauf sie
haben ihr bekenntnis und ihren mini
gesamt abgegeben aber sie haben ein
recht darauf dass der der bundeskanzler
werden will hier klipp und klar sagt ob
er mit einer partei die die nato
auflösen will den verfassungsschutz
auflösen will die bundeswehr abrüsten
will statt sie zu stärken die kommando
spezialkräfte auflösen will wie bei
jedem europäischen einigungsvertrags
maastricht amsterdam nizza lissabon
immer nein gesagt
ob sie wirklich wollen herr scholz diese
leute in eine potenzielle
bundesregierung hinein zu rufen es ist
nicht so schwer nein zu sagen ich sage
ihnen wir werden mit ihnen nicht
koalieren
ich sage
ich sage der afd mit ihnen kooperieren
wir nicht verhandeln wir nicht und
werden wir nie koalieren wir tun alles
dass sie nicht mehr in deutschen
parlamenten vertreten sind das ist unser
kampf gegen ihre haltung und diese
diese klarheit
diese klarheit diese klarheit von
demokraten gegen bestimmte positionen
die übrigens helmut schmidt auf den sie
sich neuerdings genauso gerne berufen
wie auf angela merkel gerd schröder höre
ich nicht so laut bei ihren berufungen
aber helmut schmidt und angela merkel
sind jetzt benchmarks helmut schmidt
hätte in dieser frage und hat immer in
dieser frage klar gestanden gegen links-
und rechtsextreme und deshalb wünsche
ich mir dass diese klarheit punkt das
ist die frage um die es bei der
bundestagswahl geht und da werden wir
alles tun dass es nicht zu einem rot rot
grünen bündnis in deutschland kommen das
wirklich verstehen